AND GET THIS HEARING STARTED.
TODAY WE ARE DISCUSSING BUDGET
PROPOSAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
THE BOARDOF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN THE MILITARY THE
DEPARTMENT FOR EACH ITEM THE
SPEAKERS ARE LISTED AND SPEAKING
ORDER AND THE AGENDA. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BEGIN WITH THOSE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM FOLLOWED BY
PHONE TESTIMONY. EACH PERSON
WILL HAVE UP TO ONE MINUTE TO
SPEAK. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR STREAMING
THIS HEARING. THAT NUMBER IS. A
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX- THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND STAFF
WILL ASSIST YOU. WE WILL NOT BE
TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY. ON A
WELCOME ARCHER OF BUDGET MISTER
TEEN- HERE TODAY AS WELL. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE ONE.
IF YOUR PANELISTS PLEASE PROCEED
TO SPEAK ONCE A SPEAKER BEFORE
HE HAS COMPLETED THE REMARKS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR ME TO
PROMPT YOU- UNLESS WE GET OUR
FIRST ISSUE WITH A LONG TERM
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE STRATEGY.
AND THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING ON WHICH.
DO WE HAVE. MR- WE HAVE THE
EMBARK CDCR. THIS IS BATTLING A
PLAGUE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OFFICE OF
THE SCHOOL SERVICES I BELIEVE
MISTER BORGES'S HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES JOINING- I CAN GO
AHEAD AND PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW- HOWEVER WHICH WOULD BE
A DISCUSSION I BELIEVE WILL NEED
TO. WAIT FOR HIM TO RESOLVE
THOSE ISSUES BUT I CAN DO PER I
CAN PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW
STATEMENT IF YOU BELIEVE THAT
WOULD BE HOW WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND WAIT- MISTER CLARK. YEAH.
YEAH MARKERS ARE PERFECT FOR
EACH OTHER. MICHAEL PACKER. OKAY. WELL FEET EASIER TRIES TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR- TECHNICAL ISSUES
TO GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA GO OUT
OF ORDER IN THE AGENDA AND IF
THE PANELISTS ALREADY MOVED TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. WHICH IS DNA
ID FUND RESTORATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MADAM CHAIR- AND THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ASHLEY
HARPER BUDGET OFFICER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES A ONE TIME TECHNICAL
REVENUE BACK FILL OF FORTY SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO BACK FILL THE CONTINUED
DECLINE IN DNA I. D. FUND
REVENUES TO SUPPORT DOJ'S BUREAU
FORENSIC SERVICES WHICH PROVIDES
STATEWIDE FORENSIC LABORATORY
OPERATION. THE PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THAT DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
AUGMENT THE APPROPRIATION SHOULD
FUNDS BE INSUFFICIENT TO DUE TO
CONTINUED REVENUE DECLINES
REVENUES TO THE DEMANDING FUND
HAVE DECREASED FROM SIXTY NINE
MILLION IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN TO THIRTY TWO MILLION
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
WITH THE TOTAL FUNDING NEEDS OF
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE BUREAU'S
CURRENT LEVEL. OF STATEWIDE
PUBLIC SAFETY FORENSICS SERVICES
FUND IS ANTICIPATED TO IN
CURRENT OPERATIONAL SHORTFALL OF
FORTY SIX MILLION AND POSSIBLY
MORE DEPENDING ON THE FUTURE OF
JEANNIE ID FIND REVENUES ABSENT
REVENUE BACKFILL SOLUTION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
THE FUND WILL BE INSOLVENT-
PURSUANT TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT I DO J. RECENTLY
SUBMITTED A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH OUTLINED
POTENTIAL FUTURE FUNDING OPTIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION. I DO J. REMAINS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFY A
PERMANENT FUNDING SOLUTION FOR
THIS CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY WORK
LOOK AT WITH THAT MYSELF AND
BARRY MILLER OUR CHIEF OF THE
BUREAU OF FORENSIC SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS PROPOSAL. FOR
ANY DELAY WITH A LOT ANALYST'S
OFFICE- WOULDN'T KNOW THAT THIS
IS ONE OF THE STATE FUNDS THAT
IS IMPACTED BY DECLINING
CRIMINAL FINING PEOPLE EVAN IS
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS TALKED ABOUT IN
PRIOR HEARINGS. SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO THIS FUND WE ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PARTIALLY SUPPORT BFS. BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND TO PROVIDE DOJ WITH
DIRECTION ON HOW MUCH OF BFS
OPERATIONS- SHOULD BE COMING
FROM LOCAL AGENCIES SUCH AS A
THIRD OR A HALF. AND SO THIS
WOULD GENERALLY REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED ON AN ONGOING
BASIS TO BACK FILL THIS FINE
INTO SUPPORT. BFS ADDITIONALLY
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THIS IS MORE
EQUITABLE THAN THE EXISTING
SYSTEM IN WHICH CERTAIN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE RECEIVING
SERVICES AT NO CHARGE WHILE
OTHER. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
PAYING TO SUPPORT THEIR OWN
LABORATORIES. SINCE THE AGENCIES
RECEIVING BFS SERVICES WOULD NOW
BE REQUIRED TO PAY FOR A PORTION
OF THE SERVICES THAT THEY
RECEIVE IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
THEM WITH GREATER INCENTIVE TO
PRIORITIZE THE WORKLOAD THAT'S
BEING SENT TO DOJ. DOJ WOULD
STILL HAVE FLEXIBILITY IN
DETERMINING HOW TO CALCULATE
EACH AGENCIES SHARE BASED ON THE
SERVICES THAT IT RECEIVES AND
CAN CONSIDER VARIOUS FACTORS
INCLUDING EQUITY CONCERNS SIZE
OF AGENCY- THE TYPE OF SERVICES
PROVIDED AS WELL AS THE SPEED OF
THE SERVICE. WE ARE RECOMMENDING
A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO
PROVIDE- TIME FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS NEW
FUNDING FRAMEWORK AS WELL AS TO
ALLOW FOR LOCAL AGENCIES TO
ADAPT TO THAT. SO IN LINE WITH
THAT WE ARE RECOMMENDING
APPROVAL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO MAINTAIN SERVICES IN
THE BUDGET YEAR BUT SHIFTED TO
THIS NEW FUNDING FRAMEWORK
BEGINNING AT TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU. AND THIS
IS KEVIN CLARK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE NO
FOR NO SIGNIFICANT FURTHER COM.
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME OTHERWISE
OTHER THAN NOTING THAT. DOJ JUST
RECENTLY RELEASED THE REPORT ON
MARCH TENTH DETAILING SIX UNIQUE
APPROACHES TO ADDRESSING THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT WITHIN THE
BUREAU. OF FORENSIC SERVICES AND
SO ARE WE FINANCIAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE TRADEOFFS OF EACH APPROACH-
IN OUR CONTINUING AND HAPPY TO
HAVE. CONVERSATIONS ARE ONGOING. WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
PARLIAMENT- OKAY THANK YOU ARE
JUST JUST QUICKLY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING THAT WE
HAVE THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON ALLELES
RECOMMENDATION- TO HAVE. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS- PAY A PORTION OF
THESE COST. YEAH WE'RE STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING ALL OF
THE OPTIONS- AND NOT- NOT
PREPARED SAID ABOUT A SPECIFIC
PATH FORWARD AT THIS TIME BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN LA- AND THAT'S
APARTMENT. TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
MAKE MAKE MUCH SENSE FOR THE
BOARD. THE END AND THEN JUST TO
BE CLEAR THAT- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS TRYING TO FIND A LONG
TERM SOLUTION SO WE DON'T HAVE
TO DO THESE CONTINUOUS. THAT
FILLS. YEAH WE'RE WE'RE OPEN
SAID VIOLATING ALL OPTIONS TO
ADDRESS THE SOLVENCY THE
INSOLVENCY ISSUE IN THAT THE
FUNDS. ARE AND THEN JUST TO BE
CARE FOR MYSELF I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU S. YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THIS AND COME BACK TO US.
THAT WE FIND A PERMANENT FIX AND
NOT JUST KEEP PASSING THIS ON
THE BUCKET FILLS THE RESPONSIBLE
TO KNOW WE HAVE A PROBLEM. AND
NOT ADDRESS THAT- PROPERLY AND
SO WHETHER IT'S- ALLELES
RECOMMENDATION ARE ONE OF THE
OTHER SIX THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU I DO HOPE WE COME UP WITH A
LONG TERM STRATEGY SOONER THAN
LATER. I WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT.
THE OTHER MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR
. OKAY SEEN NOT ONE I THINK YOU
WERE GONNA GO AHEAD AND CLOSE
OFF THAT I DON'T FOR NOW- WE'RE
NOT AGAIN WANTED TO GETTING
VOTES TODAY ON ANYTHING SO. FAR
I MEAN THAT WOULD BE WILL STAY
OPEN WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE OFF
THE DISCUSSION ONLY- WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND RETURN TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE. E DO HAVE. CDC ARE
I THINK TRAINING THIS VIA
TELEPHONE. YES MADAM CHAIR- MY
NAME IS DAN BORGEN THE DIRECTOR
OF THE FACILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION AND MANAGEMENT
DIVISION FOR- THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION I
WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR THE
INCONVENIENCE OF NOT BEING ABLE
TO JOIN THROUGH WEBEX I DO
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
ASSEMBLY TECHNICAL STAFF- WENT
THROUGH TO TRY TO GET ME- JOINED
IN. I'LL GO AHEAD AND START
PRESENT ON THE- THE I. ISSUE
NUMBER ONE- THE MASTER PLAN
ANNUAL REPORT KNOWN BY THE
ACRONYM EMPOWER. ANNUALLY
PROVIDES INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON CURRENT PROJECTS.
RECENTLY COMPLETED PROJECTS AND
PROJECTS THAT ARE REQUESTING
FUNDING FOR EITHER BUDGET YEAR
OR BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE. THE
EMPIRE WAS FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING
FUNDING PROPOSALS UNDER
CONSIDERATION IN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS AND- DUE TO THE
FOCUS FIVE PREVIOUSLY DID NOT
PROVIDE A LONG TERM PICTURE OF
CCAR'S FACILITY NEEDS. IN
RESPONSE TO REQUESTS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FOR A VIEW OF WHAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS WERE
PROJECTED TO BE NEEDED OVER A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME AND THEN
SHOWN IN THE EMPOWER. THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
OR S. R. L. WAS ADOPTED WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. TO
DEVELOP OUR RESPONSE TO THE S.
R. L. CDC ARE REVIEWED SEVERAL
SOURCES OF DATA REGARDING
CURRENT INTRODUCTION CONDITIONS.
TO IDENTIFY PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT WERE
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH TO BOARD
PRIVATIZATION DURING THE NEXT
TEN YEARS. THE INCLUSION OF THIS
INFORMATION HAS GREATLY ENHANCED
THE VALUE OF THE- PARK AS A
LONGER TERM PLANNING DOCUMENT
ONE COMPARED TO THE M. PARTS PER
YEAR. REMAINING PORTIONS OF THE
S. R. L. WERE DRESSED IN A
NARRATIVE SUPPLEMENT RELEASED
WITH THE M. PARK. AS IDENTIFIED
IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S AGENDA THE
ADDITIONAL PORTIONS OF THE S. R.
L. INCLUDED DISCUSSIONS ON.
WHETHER ANY OF THE PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED MA'AM PART WORKS TO
NEVER GET SCALE THAT OTHER
ALTERNATIVES. SUCH AS
CONSOLIDATION OF PRESENTS SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED. HOW THE PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED INAMDAR SUPPORT A
LONG TERM DURABLE PORTFOLIO
FACILITIES FOR CDC ARE.
INDESCRIBABLE STEPS TAKEN IN
PROJECT PLANNING AND
PRIORITIZATION TO MINIMIZE
INVESTMENT IN PRISONS THAT MAY
BE CONSIDERED FOR FUTURE
CLOSURES. GDPR'S UNDERSTANDING
OF THE S. R. L. WAS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAS LOOKING FOR A
DEEPER DIVE REGARDING LARGE
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE NEEDED
OUR VARIOUS INSTITUTIONS OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS. THE
INFORMATION SUBMITTED IDENTIFIES
THESE ANTICIPATED PROJECT NEEDS
OF CDCR ACTIVE INSTITUTIONS.
BASED ON OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE ESTARÁ REQUEST CCAR'S REPORT
WAS IT WHAT WAS RESPONSIVE TO
THE ESTARÁ. SINCE THE RELEASE OF
pTHE LEGISLATURE WAS SEEKING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT WAS
NOT INCLUDED IN CDCR RESPONSE.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ARE ON THIS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. EVEN
WITH THESE CONCERNS THE M. R.
AND S. R. L. IN SPECIFICALLY THE%
TEN YEAR PROJECTION OF
SIGNIFICANT FACILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. PROVIDES A
MORE TRANSPARENT VIEW OF FUTURE
FACILITY INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
THAN WAS PREVIOUSLY AVAILABLE TO
THE LEGISLATURE. THE FUNDING
REQUEST FROM CDC ARE THAT ARE
LISTED UNDER ISSUE SEVEN OF
TODAY'S AGENDA ARE REQUESTED BY
CDC ARE AT THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
STATION THE DEPARTMENT TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE PROVISION OF MENTAL
HEALTH. MEDICAL CARE SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT
CONSISTENCY DISCHARGE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND TO ADDRESS
KEY INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS
WATER. COOLING AND SECURITY
COMMUNICATIONS. DETAILED
INFORMATION REGARDING THE NEEDS
ADDRESSED BY EACH OF THESE
PROJECTS- IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO BUDGET REQUEST INCLUDING
ALTERNATIVES CONSIDER FOR THESE
PROJECTS AND HOW THE PROJECT
SPENT WITH A DURABLE CAL POLY-
OF FACILITIES. HAS BEEN PROVIDED
IN THE- CBCP DOCUMENTS THAT
ACCOMPANIED THE- GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. SO I THINK- THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
ON THIS INFORMATIONAL ITEM AND
I'LL BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY. HAVE- DURING
DURING THIS HEARING. CAITLIN
O'NEILL WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME THE BILL. L. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT WAS. AND THERE ON FOOT
TRUMP I DON'T. NO ONE'S ON HELLO
YEAH MONDAY. WE NEED HER SON SO
SORRY. I CAN I CAN GET. CAITLIN
O'NEILL AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE DON'T HAVE
A RECOMMENDATION ON THIS- ITEM
AND GIVEN THAT IT'S NOT A
PROPOSAL BUT I DO HAVE SOME
GENERAL COMMENTS FOR THE FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION I'M
WHICH ARE THAT WE FOUND THAT THE
REPORT THAT THE REPORT WAS NOT
FULLY RESPONSIVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S DIRECTION FOR TWO
MAIN REASONS. WHICH ARE- ONE THE
REPORT ASSUMES THAT ALL
FACILITIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
OPERATION WILL CONTINUE TO BE AN
OPERATION TEN YEARS FROM NOW
DESPITE THE FACT THAT. B.
POPULATION PROJECTIONS SUGGEST
THAT THE STATE COULD BE IN A
POSITION TO CLOSE AROUND FIVE
PERCENT- FIVE PRISONS WITHIN THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AND DESPITE
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTION TO
SEEK OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONSOLIDATE PRESENCE TO ACHIEVE
EFFICIENCIES. TO THE IDENTIFIED
PROJECTS ARE NOT AS WE
UNDERSTAND BASED ON A
SYSTEMATIC- ASSESSMENT OF BE
ANTICIPATED INMATE
REHABILITATION AND HEALTHCARE
NEEDS THAT. HEALTHCARE INNER
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS IN OTHER
WORDS IT'S SORT OF WAS A SILO
TO. LOOK AT MORE PROJECT
TRADITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES I GUESS YOU COULD SAY
SUCH AS REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
AND HEALTH SAFETY X. SENTARA-
BUT NOT A LOOK AT THE
PROGRAMMATIC INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS IF YOU WELL- IN THIS WAS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE RE. WITH
DESCRIBE HOW THE IDENTIFIED
PROJECTS SUPPORT A LONG TERM.
DURABLE PORTFOLIO OF FACILITIES
TO MEET THE DEPARTMENT'S MISSION
AND THE STATE'S LONG TERM. NEED
FOR PRISON CAPACITY. IN ADDITION
WHILE THE S. R. L. DIDN'T
DIRECTLY REQUIRE THIS- WE NOTE
THAT THE PLAN DOES NOT CONSIDER
THE SPREAD OF AIRBORNE DISEASE
AND ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE- IN MULTIPLE
EXPERTS HAVE TESTIFIED THAT IN
COURT THAT- THE ARCHITECTURE OF
SAN QUENTIN HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC WITH
THE SPREAD OF COVE AND- IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT. OTHER PRISONS
HAVE SIMILAR PROBLEMS THAT JUST
HAVEN'T BEEN UNDER AS MUCH
SCRUTINY AT SAN QUENTIN SO
THERE'S LESS INFORMATION BUT-
THAT BEING SAID THE REPORT DID
NOT INCLUDE A SYSTEMATIC
ASSESSMENT OF THAT FACTOR AS IT
RELATES TO INFRASTRUCTURE- AND
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY WHETHER
OR NOT. THE REPORT IS OR ISN'T
RESPONSIVE IT IT. WHAT IT DOES
SEEM CLEAR IS THAT THE LIST OF
PROJECTS MAY ON THE ONE HAND
INCLUDE. PROJECTS AT THE STATE
ULTIMATELY WON'T NEED TO PURSUE
BECAUSE- THOSE FACILITIES MAY BE
CLOSED AND ON THE OTHER HAND MAY
NOT INCLUDE CERTAIN PROJECTS OF
THE STATE MAY NEED TO PURSUE.
PURSUE FOR. AREAS PROGRAMMATIC
NEEDS SUCH AS REHABILITATION OR
HEALTH CARE THANK YOU. I JUST
NAMING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
EMPIRE THIS YEAR PROVIDES MORE
INFORMATION THAT HAS IN PREVIOUS
YEARS AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
REPORT IS A GOOD OVERVIEW OF
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
AND POTENTIAL FUTURE PROJECTS
PROJECTED FOR THE NEXT TEN
YEARS- I DO WANT TO REITERATE
MISTER BOARD STATEMENT THAT
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE INTENDED
PRIMARILY TO BE PLANNING
DOCUMENTS. FOR WHAT PROJECTS THE
DEPARTMENT MAY SPEAK IN THE
FUTURE- THE PROJECTS ARE
IDENTFIED ARE LARGELY
CONCEPTUAL AND ARE NOT INTENDED
TO BE JUSTIFICATION FOR PROJECTS
INCLUDED IN THAT TWENTY TWENTY
PROPOSED BUDGET I THAT SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS THE
SENSITIVITY AND CONCERN ABOUT
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- FUNDING AT THE
STATE PRISON POPULATION IS
PROJECTED TO DECLINE IN FUTURE
YEARS. HOWEVER THAT PROPOSALS
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND FOR
INCLUSION IN THE TWENTY TWENTY-
BUDGET REPRESENT THE MOST
IMMEDIATE NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THE SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION
AND CONTINUATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S MISSIONS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU AND MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
I'M GONNA MAKE A COMMENT AND
ALLOW MY COLLEAGUES TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE MINUTE ISSUE
GOING ON LONG BEFORE I BECAME
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
I WILL HAVE A SET OF QUESTIONS
AT THE END BUT- I WANT TO TALK
DIRECTLY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FIGHT. FINANCED AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT YOU DO UNDERSTAND THE
SENSITIVITY I THINK THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR
ABOUT EXPECTATIONS OF
INFORMATION WE WANT- ABOUT OUR
DUTY AS AN EQUAL PARTNER WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND- IN THIS
PROCESS- AND- WHILE YOU MIGHT
HAVE PROVIDED MORE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE HAD IN THE PAST
IT'S STILL NOT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION. THE PIECES OF
INFORMATION WE ARE ASKING FOR IT
SO- IT FILLS IN GENUINE CITIES
TO HEAR THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THE
SENSITIVITIES. OF WHAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE IN HERE THIS
COMMITTEE WANTS. US A FORMER
CLASSROOM TEACHER I CONSIDER OF
IT THINK ABOUT THE STUDENTS THAT
WOULD TELL ME- I WOULD GIVE AN
ASSIGNMENT IT WOULD TELL ME BUT
I SUBMIT THAT THIS IS JUST GIVE
ME CREDIT FOR THAT I WAS LIKE NO
IT'S NOT TRUE THAT YOU SUBMITTED
SOMETHING. THAT A STATEMENT IS
PRETTY CLEAR IT'S BEEN PRETTY
CLEAR LONG BEFORE I BECAME THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE- SO
PRETTY FRUSTRATED- BY BY WHAT
HAS BEEN PRESENTED TO US AND
HARD FOR ME TO BE APPRECIATIVE.
FOR THE NEW INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE WHEN IT'S NOT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT. THINGS LIKE PRESENT-
CAN MAKE POPULATION PROJECTIONS
AND REDUCTIONS THAT WE- WERE
EXPECTING ON THE WAY AND SO WANT
TO MAKE MY DISSATISFACTION HERE.
BUT ALSO GIVEN THAT I HAVE
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE LONGER THAN I HAVE AND
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING DESPITE
LONGER THAN I HAVE WANT TO GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD
WITH QUESTIONS- STARTING WITH.
THE MISS WALDRON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF HATE I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE GENTLEMAN FROM
CDC ARE- WE KNOW COVERT BROUGHT
TO LIGHT A LOT OF DEFICIENCIES
IN THE PRISON SYSTEM- YOU KNOW
NOT ONLY THE LACK OF SPACE
WHISTLES DISTANCING THE- THE
YARD. IN ADEQUATE TECHNOLOGY
THAT WAS AVAILABLE- AS WELL AS A
MYRIAD OF OTHER THINGS- BOTH IN
THE ARCHITECTURE IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHAT UPGRADES IF
ANY THAT WE'RE SEEING HERE
BECAUSE THEY LOOK A LOT OF THEM
ON THE LIST TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE. OUR IN OUR YOU KNOW
RELATIONS WHAT WE LEARNED DURING
COVED. AND- YOU KNOW WE- HAD IT
IN MY DISCUSSIONS WITH CDCR
FOLKS OVER THE YEARS. THEY ADMIT
AND IN THEIR OWN WORDS SAY THAT
THESE FACILITIES ARE DILAPIDATED
- WORKING IN A WHICH WHICH IF
ANY ON THIS LIST ARE IN RELATION
TO WHAT WE LEARNED IN LIGHT OF
COVED IN THOSE DEFICIENCIES. IN
A IN A WAY THAT WE CAN PREVENT
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT HAPPENED
IN THE PANDEMIC THAT WE SAW. ALL
RIGHT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION AGAIN THIS IS- DEAN
BORG I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING
ON CAMERA- THE DEPARTMENT HAS
TAKEN MANY STEPS OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS RELATED TO- COLD AND-
IN ORDER TO ADJUST BOTH OUR
OPERATIONAL PROCEDURES. AND OUR
MAINTENANCE PROCEDURES- TO
ADDRESS- TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
MINIMISE THE- MINIMIZE THE
POSSIBILITIES OF SPREAD SAYING
IT IS AN AIRBORNE- AIRBORNE
SPREAD DISEASE- MANY
OPERATIONAL- CHANGES REGARDING-
OCCUPANCY AND- BECAUSE WILL
DISTANCING HAVE OCCURRED.
THROUGHOUT THE INSTITUTIONS- I
YOU KNOW AND I'VE BEEN THERE
WE'VE LEARNED ALONG THE WAY AS
AS WE GO- WHEN IT COMES TO THE-
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE A LOT OF
ATTENTION HAS BEEN PAID TO-
VENTILATION AND THE AND THE ROLE
IT PLAYS- DEPARTMENT- DID
UPGRADE ALL- AIR HANDLING UNITS.
THAT RECIRCULATE AIR AS PART OF
ITS HEATING OR COOLING
OPERATIONS TO USING MERV
THIRTEEN FILTERS- WHICH WASA
HIGHER EFFICIENCY FILTER AND-
RECOMMENDED BY A NUMBER OF
INDUSTRY GROUPS- AS A- A GOOD
WAY OF REDUCING THE POSSIBILITY
OF A SPREADING- THE- VIRUS
THROUGH- THROUGH VENTILATION- WE
ALSO MAXIMIZE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE USE OF A DIRECT OUTSIDE
AIR RATHER THAN RECIRCULATION-
AGAIN TO. MINIMIZE THE-
MINIMIZED POSSIBILITIES OF
SPREADING IT THAT WAY-
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO- REVIEW
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT REPORTS-
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY. TO LOOK
AT- YOU KNOW DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT- THINGS COULD TO COULD BE
ADJUSTED DOWN THE ROAD- THERE
ARE NO DIRECT PROJECTS IN HERE-
DIRECTLY- RELATED COBIT. BARLEY
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE- LITERATURE
OUT THERE IS CONTINUING TO
EVOLVE SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP OUR EYE ON THAT
AND SEE WHAT- NEEDS TO BE DONE-
TO ADJUST THE OPERATION. MORE
COMPONENT PARTS OF OUR
VENTILATION SYSTEMS. I JUST
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADDRESS- THE-
STATEMENT ABOUT- HAS ALWAYS BEEN
AND DILAPIDATED CONDITION- WE
HAVE- BEEN FORTY- IN PARTNERSHIP
ALLEGED. TO RECEIVE A OF FUNDING
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS- WE TO A
MILLION. IN ONE TIME FOR ME
FUNDING BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND- JUST THIS PAST YEAR- IT
OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A ROOF REPLACEMENT
FUNDING HAS BEEN APPROVED-
BETWEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND
THIS PAST YEAR- AND- THE ANNUAL
MAINTENANCE FUNDING THE
DEPARTMENT HAS HAS INCREASED
FROM. APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
MILLION TO OVER SEVENTY MILLION
THANKS TO- INCREASES IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SO THAT MONEYIS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE- OUT THERE. THE
CONDITIONS THAT EXISTED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE LAST DECADE ARE-
BEING. ARE ARE BEING ADDRESSED
IN LARGE PART THROUGH THE ONE
TIME PROJECTS AND THE ANNUAL-
MAINTENANCE FUNDING INCREASE IS
ALLOWING INSTITUTIONS TO. NOT
RUN THEIR EQUIPMENT UNTIL IT
FAILED BUT TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY AIR HANDLING UNITS
PUMPS OTHER KEY PIECES OF
MACHINERY THAT- ARE BREAKING
DOWN ON A FREQUENT BASIS AND
BEING ABLE TO REPLACE THAT. WITH
THE THEIR ANNUAL FUNDING AMOUNT
SO WE THINK THAT THERE IS A
CHANGE IN THE WAY THE CONDITIONS
OUT THERE- THAT'LL CONTINUE TO-
INCREASE. FOR THE BETTER- IN THE
COMING YEARS. JUST A FOLLOW UP
THING YOU- YOU KNOW IN ADDITION
WE ALSO SAW. THAT DURING THE
EMERGENCY. IT COULD BE COVERED
IT COULD BE A NATURAL DISASTER
FOR ALL WE KNOW- WE SAW THAT
FAMILIES WERE UNABLE TO CONTACT
THEIR LOVED ONES- DURING THAT
TIME BECAUSE OF. ISSUES WITH
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS OR WHAT
HAVE YOU- AS WELL AS TREAT SOME
TRAINING WAS UNAVAILABLE
COUNSELING. ENDED IN SOME PLACES
AT A TIME WHEN PEOPLE NEEDED IT
THE MOST- WHAT IS BEING PLAN TO
IMPROVE THE TECHNOLOGY AND
PRISONS. SO THAT THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN. IN IN THESE TIMES. LET ME PROVIDE WHAT
INFORMATION I CAN ON THAT- I DO
HAVE ANOTHER COLLEAGUE NOT A
PART OF TODAY'S HEARING WHO IS
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR- THE
TECHNOLOGICAL ASPECTS OUT OF THE
INSTITUTIONS- I DO KNOW THAT-
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF. PROGRAMS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER WAY
THAT PARTLY WERE DONE IN
RESPONSE TO COBIT OR WERE IN THE
WORKS HARD CODED REGARDING VIDEO
VISITATION- WE ARE ALSO-
IMPLEMENTING THE- COMMUNICATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM WHICH IS
REPLACING THE- PHONE- THE INMATE
MORE **** TELEPHONE SYSTEM WITH
A TABLET- WHICH WILL INCREASE-
COMMUNICATION CAPABILITIES SO
THERE ARE A NUMBER NUMBER WAY-
WAYS- THAT ARE GOING ON TO
INCREASE- COMMUNICATION- THE-
INCARCERATED POPULATION. AND
THEIR LOVED ONES. OKAY SO. IS
THERE A TIMELINE FOR THAT ARE
THERE ON THE WAY BUT- WILL THEY
BE IN ALL OF FACILITIES I THINK
WOULD BE. A. I. EITHER TO BE
ABOUT THE FIVE I COULD ASK MY
COLLEAGUE TO PUT TOGETHER SOME
INFORMATION- AND- TRUE I WOULD
MISS THE PLANE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT INFORMATION GETS GETS BACK
TO YOU AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY AND JUST. IF I
COULD HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION- SO
IT AS FAR AS IMPROVEMENTS I'M
LOOKING IN THE LIST OF THEM
IMPROVE AND REPLACE- A LOT WHICH
IS NEEDED DEFINITELY BUT ALSO
THE OUTLOOK AS YOU KNOW WHAT THE
PRISONS ANY. YOU KNOW GOIG OUT
TEN TWENTY YEARS WE TALK ABOUT
SOME REALIGNMENT OF FOLKS IF OF
A PRISONER TO IS CLOSE WE DON'T
KNOW WHICH ONES THOSE WILL BE
BUT THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN THAT ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE
WILL BE MOVED DOWN TO COUNTY
LEVEL OR- OR OTHER. TYPES OF
SITUATIONS A LOT OF TIMES FOLKS
HAVE MOVED INTO ANOTHER FACILITY
AND WE DON'T NECESSARILY SEE A
REDUCTION IN. IN ANOTHER
FACILITY SO WE'RE BASICALLY
MOVING PEOPLE AROUND AND SOME OF
THE PLANNING WOULD NEED TO BE-
YOU KNOW RELATIVE TO THE FACT
THAT- FOR SOME FACILITIES MAY
INCREASE POPULATION AS AS FOLKS
MOVED AROUND. BUT I GUESS THAT
IS JUST THE COMMON. I WOULD HOPE
THAT AS WE LOOK OUT INTO THE
FUTURE THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
LOOKING AT BRICK AND MORTAR BUT
TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE CONDITIONS
NOT ONLY FOR THE PEOPLE INSIDE
BUT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
THERE. LOTS OF FOLKS ARE THEIR
FAMILIES VISITING LIGHTING SPACE
CLASSROOMS THINGS THAT- ARE
MORE- HAVE MORE OF A HUMAN FEEL.
TO THEM AS WE LOOK AT REPLACING
AND REPAIRING. THAT'S MY COMMENT
THANK YOU. MISTER LUCKY. YEAH I
KNOW THAT- ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS OF QUITE A- A
SON OF MONEY AND- WE HAVE FORTY
FIVE. ROGIC SHARED THAT ARE
LISTED ON HERE BUT THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE ANY PRIORITIZATION. A
WHICH WOULD BE MORE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE FACT THAT IT'S VERY
LIKELY THAT NOT EVERYONE OF
THESE PROJECTS WOULD GET FUNDED
AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT IS
THERE SOME KIND OF INTERNAL
PRIORITIZATION THAT YOU'D LIKE
TO SHARE THAT MIGHT BE A BECOME
AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER LUCKY FOR THAT
QUESTION- THE PRIORITIZATION-
GOES ON ON AN ANNUAL BASIS- IN
PREPARATION FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RELEASED IN EACH IN
JANUARY- SO DO WITH THAT. ANY
SORT OF PRIORITIZATION THAT THE
DEPARTMENT COULD PUT TOGETHER
RIGHT NOW WITH- FORTY FIVE
PROJECTS- WOULD BE SUBJECT TO-
TREMENDOUS CHANGE AS WE GO ALONG
BECAUSE W HAVE TO BE READY TO
ADJUST TO CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES- BE THAT CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES REGARDING- THE-
POPULATION OR OR OTHER NEEDS
WITHIN. THE PRISONS CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES REGARDING-
DIFFERENT REGULATORY OR OR COURT
SITUATION SO THERE ISN'T A HARD
FAST PRIORITIZATION THAT APPLIES
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
THESE PROJECTS- WE WORK WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT- EACH YEAR WHEN WE'RE
PREPARING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REQUEST AND OF COURSE THE- ALSO
INCLUDES WORKING WITH.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANOTHER-
PURCHASE OF THESE MINISTRATION
TO THEN NARROW DOWN OUR FOCUS TO
WHAT'S GOING TO BE IN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET REQUESTS AND THEN PROVIDE
VERY DETAILED DOCUMENTS. BACKING
UP BUILD THOSE ITEMS SO THIS WAS
NOT AN ATTEMPT TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK TEN YEARS DOWN THE ROAD TO
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THE
UNIVERSAL PROJECTS THAT WE FEEL
ARE ARE IMPORTANT- BUT AS FAR AS
WHICH PROJECTS THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD BE REQUESTING FUNDING FOR-
THE NEXT YEAR OR THE YEAR AFTER
THE YEAR AFTER- WE'RE GOING TO
BE DOING THAT PURCHASE ACTION ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS AND BRING THAT
INFORMATION FORWARD. I. EACH
JANUARY IN THE OF GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. SO FIVE YOU. YOU'RE
TELLING ME THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IS THE ONE THAT. MAKES
THOSE OF PRIORITIZATION
DECISIONS NOT NOT YOU FOLKS. IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME
ANOTHER ARNOLD I THINK YOU KNOW.
I APOLOGIZE FOR- PROVIDING THAT
INFORMATION- THIS IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT- AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IN REVIEWING OUR
PROPOSALS IN DEVELOPING WHAT
WILL END UP IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- AT THE END OF THE END OF
THE YEAR AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS A RELEASE OF THE-
LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY. OKAY GET
WELL JUST SO YOU KNOW I DO. AS A
COMMITTEE MEMBER I CAN'T SPEAK
FOR AN ENTIRE COMMITTEE BUT I
WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO BE PART
OF THAT PRIORITIZATION DECISION
TREE SOMEHOW. AND SUGGESTION
WOULD BE GREATLY APPRECIATED
BUT- YEAH THAT'S MY REMARKS. I
DON'T THE AGENCY WOULD WANNA-
YOU GOT ELECTED YOUR CITY IS
COMMITTEES TO YOU GET TO BE PART
OF THE PROCESS I LIKE THE REST
OF THE THIRTEEN. ANY QUESTIONS
IF I CONDUCTOR WALKED I WOULD
COME ALONG MY REMARKS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALMDALE- IT JUST
BOUGHT JUST TO FOLLOW UP SO- YOU
HAVE AN ITEM SEVEN OF FOR A
VARIETY OF FROM. FOURTEEN
REQUIRES SO- CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH THE CRITERIA THAT YOU
DEVELOP TO DETERMINE THESE
REQUESTS. FOR THIS YEAR GOOD
SENSE LIKE YOU DO IT. I DO WE
HEAR YOU CORRECTLY THIS IS DONE
YEAR TO YEAR SO EVERY YEAR THE
PRIORITIES ARE DIFFERENT AND
EVERY YEAR THE CRITERIA IS
DIFFERENT. THE RIGHT YEP BUT I
WOULDN'T SAY THE CRITERIA IS
DIFFERENT THE CRITERIAS
EVALUATED EVERY YEAR THE GREAT
THING IS DONE NOTHING TO SHARE
WITH. OUR KERRY THAT BE GREAT-
CRITERIA IT HAS BEEN- YEAH IT
INVOLVES- I'M NUMBER OF ITEMS
THAT ARE OF SHARED- PRIORITIES
COULD YOU JUST WALK US THROUGH
THE STATE I MATTER I HEAR A LOT
OF- DANCING IF YOU COULD JUST.
WALK US THROUGH THE STEPS WHAT
ARE THE ITEMS. LET ME CLEAR
FIRED ARE YOU ASKING ME TO SPEAK
TO THE ISSUES THAT WHAT THE
ITEMS ARE IN ISSUE SEVEN- OR DO
YOU NOT WANT TO HEAR HOW WE
PRIVATE HOW WE PRIORITISE RATHER
THAN GOING THROUGH THE ITEMS AN
ISSUE SEVEN. I'D LIKE TO HEAR
HOW YOU- YOU WHAT YOU SAID YOU
DIDN'T PRIORITIZE- THAT WAS ONE.
SO IF YOU DO IF YOU IF YOU'RE
NOT YOU'RE SAYING YOU ARE
PRIORITIZING I LIVE WE LIVE I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES. AND I WOULD
WE DON'T LOOK AT YOUR. IN
DEVELOPING OUR FUNDING REQUEST
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
EACH YEAR. WE USE A SET OF
PRIORITIZATION WHICH DOES NOT
ASSIGN A NUMERICAL VALUE TO
EACH. BUT EQUAL REVIEWS THEM ON
AN EQUAL BASIS- THIS INCLUDES
FIRE LIFE SAFETY ISSUES THAT
HAVE COME UP. THROUGH OUR
INTERACTIONS WITH THE- STATE
FIRE MARSHAL. ITEMS RELATED TO
POOR COMPLIANCE OF THESE ARE.
ITEMS THAT HAVE COME UP-
THROUGH. OUR DEPARTMENT
INTERACTION WITH- VARIOUS COURTS
IN A CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS.
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME UP- THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT REGULATORY AGENCIES
THAT MAY- HAVE AUTHORITY OVER
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS FOR
WATER TREATMENT PLANTS.
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
ENSURING THAT- ANY NEW SPACE
THAT'S NECESSARY FOR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING IS A
PART OF THE PRIORITY- AND OF
COURSE- THE STAFF AND POPULATION
SAFETY ARE IMPORTANT SO ALL OF
THE PROJECTS ARE LOOKED AT WITH
THAT CONTEXT. AND THE ONES THAT
HAVE THE HIGHEST- NEED FOR THE
COMING YEAR BASED UPON THE
CONTEXT OF THOSE FIVE MAIN
PRIORITIES IS HOW WE ESTABLISH
OUR PRIORITIES ARE. THANK YOU
SINCE SINCE YOU DON'T PUT A
NUMERIC VALUE CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH HOW YOU DETERMINE WHICH
PROJECTS TO SUBMIT. WELL IN
PARTICULAR THE ITEMS ARE LISTED
UNDER AND IN ISSUE SEVEN- THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE ITEMS
WITH ONLY TWO EXCEPTIONS ARE
ITEMS THAT HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED- IN PRIOR BUDGET ACTION
FOR SOME LEVEL OF FUNDING IN
MOST CASES IT'S BEEN FOR THE-
THE FIRST OR SECOND PLAGUE OF
DESIGN FUNDING. AND SO OUR FIRST
PRIORITY AND PUTTING THAT
TOGETHER IS TO CONTINUE OUR
PROGRESS ON PROJECTS THAT ARE
ALREADY. UNDERWAY SO WE HAVE
RECEIVED THE FIRST- PAID THE
DESIGN FUNDING. I WILL BE
REQUESTING A SECOND PHASE OF THE
DESIGN FUNDING. FOR PROJECTING
THAT WE WILL COME FULLY COMPLETE
LEVINE DURING THE UP COMING
FISCAL YEAR THAT WILL BE
REQUESTING THE CONSTRUCTION
FUNDING FOR THOSE PROJECTS. SO
THAT IS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WHAT IS IN THE ITEMS AN ISSUE
SEVEN ARE THE ONLY TWO THAT ARE
BRAND NEW ITEMS. ONE HALF DO
WITH- PROVIDING- EXERCISE YARD
SPACE- FOR- PATIENTS THAT ARE IN
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS- AT-
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
CORCORAN- THAT ASKING FOR THE
DESIGN FUNDING FOR THE FOR THAT.
AND THE SECOND PROJECT THE ONLY
OTHER NEW PROJECT ALSO CORCORAN.
THE REQUESTED DESIGN FUNDING FOR
NEW RADIO TOWER EQUIPMENT
FAULTS- IT CURRENTLY THE- THE
PRISONS OF SECURITY
COMMUNICATIONS IS BASED ON A
TEMPORARY LOAN OF A- TRAILER
BASED SYSTEM. FROM C. H. P. AND
SO WE NEED TO REPLACE IT WITH A
PERMANENT- PERMANENT SOLUTION.
M. WALK WALKER THROUGH HOW THOSE
TWO PROJECTS. ROSE TO THE TOP OF
THE HEAP. OF THE ONE FOR THE-
THE EXERCISE YARD FOR OUR LITTLE
HEALTH CRISIS OF PATIENTS IS-
BASED UPON ON GOING WORK WITH
THE- COLEMAN COURT- REGARDING-
BEING ABLE TO MEET THE UP
PROGRAM GUIDE ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO A SUICIDE PREVENTION
AND ITEMS LIKE THAT- THE ABILITY
PROVIDE FULL COURSE OF A
TREATMENT FOR OUR PATIENTS IN
THAT LEVEL OF A CRISIS- INVOLVED
THE BILITY FOR OUTDOOR
RECREATION AND AT THIS ONE
LOCATION COMPARED TO OUR OTHER
LOCATIONS. THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
NOT AVAILABLE DUE TO THE-
LOCATION WHERE THE CRISIS CENTER
LOCATED SO IN ORDER TO- CONTINUE
TO FULFILL OUR OBLIGATIONS-
UNDER THAT CASE- THAT ONE ROSE
TO A LEVEL OF IMPORTANCE TO
BEGIN THE DESIGN PROCESS. AND
EVELYN MENTIONED WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH A TEMPORARY LOAN OF
THE TRAILER FROM C. H. P. AND C.
H. P. HAS- INDICATED THAT- THEY
THEY KNEW THAT TRAILER BACK FOR
OTHER USAGES SO WE NEED TO START
THE PROCESS EVEN THOUGH CAPITAL
OUTLAY IS CLEARLY NOT AN
OVERNIGHT PROCESS- IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO START THE PROCESS
FOR THE DESIGN FOR A PERMANENT
RADIO TOWER EQUIPMENT BALLS SO
THAT THE LOAN OF THAT. COULD. BE
RETURNED CHU CH P. OKAY OKAY AND
THEN CAN YOU ON. YOU SEE JUST
LISTED ARE A REPEAT WHAT YOU
MISTER WHICH IS FIRE LIFE SAFETY
- CORE COMPLIANCE REGULATORY.
COMPLIANCE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING AND STAFFING
POPULATION SAFETY SO COULD YOU.
WALK US THROUGH ON HOW THE RADIO
TOWER EQUIPMENT VAULT- WHICH
WHICH CATEGORY THAT FALLS INTO.
THE RADIO OF ALL FALLS INTO STEP
WITH POPULATION SAFETY WITHIN
OUR SECURITY COMMUNICATION RADIO
SYSTEM THAT SERVES BOTH OF
CORCORAN AND- THE- NEIGHBORING-
TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY PERSON. VERY GOOD SO ON
. WHAT PROJECTS DIDN'T MAKE THE
LIST GIVE US A SENSE OF YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT WHAT WOULD BE THE NEXT
LEVEL DOWN. YOU COULD LOSE IT
ALL THE PROJECT INFO IN. THE
REPORT BACK TO US SO. WHAT WHAT
DIDN'T QUITE MAKE THE CUT.
WITHOUT PULLING OUT SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
THE INFORMATION PORTRAYED IN
FRONT OF ME IN A MANNER THAT
WOULD ALLOW ME TO SEE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN- CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ON THESE PROJECTS IN MANY CASES
IT WOULD. BE PROJECTS THAT AGAIN
SIMILARLY DEALING WITH FIRE LIFE
SAFETY OR REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
BUT THE CIRCUMSTANCE OF THE NEED
TO ADDRESS THAT NEED MAY NOT BE
AS URGENT AS IN THE ONES THAT
ARE ALREADY IN FOR IN FRONT OF
US AND- ARE CONTINUING THROUGH
THE DESIGN PROCESS HELLO
DESIGNER FUNDING PROCESS- IN THE
BUDGET SO WILL BE A MIXTURE OF
PROJECTS AMONG THOSE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES. IT'S JUST THAT THE
WE MAY HAVE A OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE FIRE MARSHAL OR
REGULATORY AGENCY WHICH GIVES US
A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME FOR
COMPLIANCE- THAN SOME OTHER
PROJECTS MAY REQUIRE AND SO FOR
THOSE PROJECTS OTHER MAYBE A
YEAR DELAY THE REQUESTED FUNDING
RATHER THAN HAVING THEM IN THIS
YEAR'S- PROPOSAL. SO IN OUR IN
OUR OWN. AGENDA ON PAGE FIVE IS
STATES THAT ACCORDING TO. THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT TWENTY
SIX OUT OF THIRTY FOUR PRISONS.
HAD AN FCI OF OVER 50% WHICH
MEANS THEY'RE VERY POOR TO
EXTREMELY POOR SO. I GUESS
THERE- YOU KNOW. FROM A BAD NEWS
POINT OF VIEW YOU HAVE A LOT OF
CHOICES. IN TERMS OF WHAT TO
FIX. SO I GUESS WHAT WE'RE
STRUGGLING WITH IS WE STILL
DON'T UNDERSTAND. HOW YOU.
DETERMINE WHICH ITEMS TO BRING
FORWARD TO THE COMMITTEE. IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE ANY-
METHODOLOGY- I MEAN THAT YOU
HAVE YOUR CATEGORIES BUT I STE
WE STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND OR I
DON'T UNDERSTAND MAYBE OTHER
COLLEAGUES TO UNDERSTAND- HOW.
YOU DETERMINED BASED ON THOSE
CATEGORIES WHAT. YOU'RE GOING TO
BRING FORTH. I APOLOGIZE MISTER
KING BUT I HAVE NO FURTHER
INFORMATION TO PROVIDE ON ON THE
SUBJECT- THIS IS THE WAY THE
MANNER IN WHICH WE GO THROUGH
PRIORITIES PRIORITIZING OUR MOST
IMPORTANT- NEEDS EACH YEAR-
THROUGH THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. I BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND SO WHEN YOU'RE MAKING
THE FINAL CUT HOW DO YOU MAKE
THE FINAL CUT. BECAUSE IT SEEMS
VERY RANDOM AT THIS POINT. SO
SHOULD WE IN DETERMINING OF
THESE FOURTEEN ITEM SO WE JUST
TAKE A DART BOARD AND SEE WHICH
STARTS HIT THE FOURTEENTH ITEMS
OR WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S THERE I
MEAN HELP US BECAUSE WE CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND YOUR APPROACH
WE COULD HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE FUND.
WELL WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT IN
GETTING TO THE PROJECTS THAT-
ARE EXCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN JANUARY- IT IS A LONG
PROCESS THAT CONSIDERS. OTHER
PROJECTS WORKING WITH OUR
DEPARTMENTAL STAKEHOLDERS OUR
DEPARTMENTAL LEADERSHIP. AND
THEN WORKING THROUGH THE
INTERNET BUDGET PROCESS WITH THE
PARTNER FINANCE TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE. D. E. DEPARTMENTS
HIGHEST PRIORITIES ARE
IDENTIFIED IN BEING ABLE TO THEN
MOVE FORWARD- IN BUDGET
REQUESTS. SO IT'S A PROCESS OF.
WINNOWING WITH PEOPLE CONTINUING
TO APPLY THE- BASED ON BUT THEY
STARTED WATCHING PRINCIPLE. BUT
BASED ON WHAT SO YOU SEE YOU
START OFF THE THING ABOUT WHAT
YOU COULD SAY IS THERE A REASON
WHY YOU CAN'T SAY ANYTHING MORE.
ARE YOU ARE YOU NOT ALLOWED TO
SAY ANYTHING MORE GIVING YOU THE
AND- I'M GIVING YOU THE I'M
EXPLAINING THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
OKAY WILL WALK US THROUGH THE
MOST DEFINITE IT WITH THEIR OWN
LEVEL OF SO YOU YOU YOU GET YOU
GET INTO THE ROOM YOU GOT
STAKEHOLDERS. YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT I DON'T KNOW I SNIOR
HUNTER ME YOU WOULD LITERALLY
YOU'VE YOU'VE DOCUMENTED VERY
THOROUGHLY. YOU KNOW LET'S LARGE. LIST OF PROJECTS OR HOW DO YOU
. I IT DOWN TO THIS A- FOURTEEN.
AS I SAID WE WORK WITH DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE DEPARTMENT BE
UNDERSTAND YOU WORK HOW THE HOW
THE HUNDRED FIVE HOW DO YOU DO
THAT- WHEN YOU SAY YOU WORK WITH
AND HOW DO YOU WANT WITH THEM
AND HOW DO YOU COME UP WITH A
BASED ON WHAT I MEAN THIS THIS
IS A LIKE EVERY DEPARTMENT EVERY
DAY DECEMBER PRESENT GET LIKE
ONE CHOICE AND THEN THE
DEPARTMENT TAKES EVERY CHOICE
AND SAYS YOU KNOW WE JUST PICKED
HERE PICKED OUT HERE LIKE WHAT.
WHAT WHAT IS IT. IF I MAY
CONTINUE PLEASE- WE- WILL WORK
WITH THESE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS- IN MENTAL HEALTH
HEALTH CARE D. A. I. REAL BILL
KIND OF SERVICES. GET THEIR
INPUT ON THE VARIETY PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN REQUESTED FROM
THE INSTITUTIONS. AT THE SAME
TIME FIND OUT WHETHER THEY HAVE
ANY PRIORITIES OF THEIR OWN THAT
WERE NOT LISTED. BY THE
INSTITUTIONS. WHEN WE GATHER
THAT INFORMATION- A OF.
COMPONENTS OF THE DIVISION THAT
I REPRESENT MORE PUT TOGETHER
RECOMMENDATIONS BASED UPON THAT
INFORMATION. AND THEN WE COMPARE
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS BACK WITH
THE- DIRECTORS AND THAT LEAD. TO
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
DEPARTMENT- D. A. HIGH RESULTED
OF SERVICES. AGAIN HEALTH CARE
AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE- IN
INSIGNIFICANCE CONCURRENCE OF
THOSE PRIORITIES. WAR MAKE ANY
ADJUSTMENTS THAT THEY REQUEST-
THEN WILL MEET WITH-
UNDERSECRETARIES AND GO THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESS- EXPLAINING-
WHAT WE'VE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
WHAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING- AND
THEN THOSE. DOCUMENTS ARE PUT
TOGETHER- WITH THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR THE PROJECTS. AND SENATE
BEGINS THE- INTERNET BUDGET
PROCESS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND CONTINUING TO ASK
QUESTIONS. ANSWER QUESTIONS-
THAT THEY HAVE. REGARDING THE
DIFFERENT- PROJECTS IN THE
JUSTIFICATIONS. AND THE- THE
NEEDS THAT WERE DRESSING. GOWN
SO. SO I GET IT LIKE YOU HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH AND OF ALL THESE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES AND IMAGINE
YOUR- REPRESENTATIVES IN THOSE
DIVISIONS ARE OBVIOUSLY.
ADVOCATING FOR THEIR- PARTY'S
SIDE COMPLETE UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IS WHAT
TICKETS TO THE UNDERSECRETARY
LEVEL. HOW DO YOU START PICKING.
AND CHOOSING WINNERS AND LOSERS
. AT THAT POINT IN TIME WE'VE
ALREADY COME UP WITH A-
PRIORITIZATION- THE IN CONCERT
WITH THE DIRECTORS OF THE
DIVISIONS THAT REPORT TO THOSE
UNDERSECRETARIES AND SO THE
UNDERSECRETARIES OF REVIEWING-
THE- RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE BY- THE DIRECTORS ARE
REPORTED THEM. THAT'S HOW THAT'S
HOW THE FINAL REVIEW IT OCCURS.
IN IN THE DARK AND HOW HOW DO
YOU GET TO THE- PRIVATIZATIONS
WITH THOSE DIRECTORS I IMAGINE
EACH OF THOSE DIRECTORS
ADVOCATING FOR THEIR OWN.
DIVISIONS I PART OF FROM USING
THE WRONG TERMINOLOGY BUT- HOW
DO YOU RECONCILE THAT. AT. AND
HAVING DISCUSSIONS THAT TALK
ABOUT SHARED PRIORITIES- WHETHER
CERTAIN PRIORITIES ARE READY TO
GO FORWARD AT THAT TIME OR NEED
MORE REVIEW IN ORDER TO GET THEM
IN A BETTER PLACE TO MOVE
FORWARD- AND REACHING CONSENSUS
WITH- WITH THESE OTHER DIRECTORS. SO WON'T WALK US THROUGH THESE
TWO PARTIES TO PUT THE TWO NEW
PRIORITIES PUT FORWARD WHAT
WHAT- WHAT- WHY YOU KNOW WHAT
SHARED VALUES TODAY- EXHIBIT.
ALL. THE- OVER THE DEPARTMENT'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND THE COMMON PROGRAM GUIDE IS
A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN-
CCAC UP FROM UP FROM AND CLEARLY
IN NURSING- STANDPOINT OR MENTAL
HEALTH- STAKEHOLDERS- FROM THE
DIRECT MENTAL HEALTH STANDPOINT
AND THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS- BECAUSE THEY OF
COURSE NEED TO HELP- HELP HAVE
PROGRAMS- WORK IT PEOPLE TO AND
FROM THE PROGRAMS SO- THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN- IN THE
NEED TO BE ABLE T THAT WE ARE
MEETING THE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT NEEDS ARE IMPORTANT TO
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT AND THAT'S HOW THE
YARD FOR. A CORPORATE WAS ABLE
TO RISE AGAIN IN PRIORITY- AND
THEN THE SECOND ONE REGARDING
SECURITY COMMUNICATIONS ARE ON
ENTERPRISE INFORMATION SYSTEMS
THE I. S. DIVISION- EASILY-
TECHNICAL- PEOPLE WHO DEAL WITH
OUR RADIO SYSTEMS ARE OUT IN THE
PRISONS- AND OF COURSE- THE
DIVISION OF THE OLD INSTITUTION
IS A MAJOR US STAKEHOLDER- AS
FAR AS THE- ABILITY TO HAVE THE-
RADIOS MARKING UP PROPERLY- AND
HAVE BEEN- UPGRADING BOTH THE I.
S. B. I'VE BEEN UPGRADING
RADIOS- AT MANY OF OUR PRISONS
TO- NEWER INTEROPERABLE WITH
THE- AND PUBLIC SAFETY
STANDARDS- BUT THAT'S UNABLE TO
HAPPEN CORCORAN INTO WE ARE ABLE
TO REPLACE THE- TRAILER THAT
WERE- UTILIZING A LOAN FROM C.
H. P. SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
INTEGRATE THE INTER OPERABILITY
STANDARDS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
RADIOS AT CORCORAN WITH THE NEW. TOWER AND THE NEW OF ALL. SO
YOU SHOULD THAT YOU KNOW YOU
SHARED IN YOUR- REPORT ON THIS
TO. OVERRIDE OF PROJECTS I THINK
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IS HOW.
RADIO TOWER IN EQUIPMENT
INVOLVED ROSE TO THE TOP BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE ALL THESE OTHER
CHALLENGES IN FRONT OF YOU. THE
THIRTEEN DO YOU WANT ANOTHER
ANSWER YOU WANT TO GO AROUND THE
CIRCLE ON MY TIMER. GET GIVE ME
A TO TWO MORE MINUTES OFF OKAY
AT. OKAY SO AGAIN ON THAT
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH THE
IMPORTANCE OF RADIO INTEROP
ABILITY AND OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH FELLOW STATE AGENCIES SUCH
AS PHD. WHO CERTAINLY HAVE
HELPED US OUT WITH THIS LOAN BUT
YOU NEED THE EQUIPMENT BACK FOR
THEIR OWN PURPOSES AND SO WHAT
WE NEED TO START THE PROCESS BY
WHICH AFTER A THREE TO FOUR YEAR
PERIOD OF TIME WILL BE ABLE TO
RETURN THE- RENTAL EQUIPMENT TO
THE LOAN EQUIPMENT TO THEM.
OKAY- ONE OF BURKE TO LAST
QUESTION SO- THE WITH ITEM WITH
THE OTHER CAR COCHRAN- REQUEST
THIS IS A MENTAL HEALTH REQUEST
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES I ESTIMATE EVERY SINGLE
FACILITY WHY WHY WAS THIS ONE
CHOSEN. THIS IS PARTICULAR WE
DON'T WE DO NOT A CRISIS BUT
THAT EVERY SINGLE INSTITUTION- I
THINK MAYBE TWENTY THIRTY THREE
BUT I'M JUST PULLING THAT NUMBER
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD- AT THE
OTHER LOCATIONS- THERE ARE-
EXERCISE- OPPORTUNITIES.
AVAILABLE ADJACENT TO WHERE THE-
CRISIS BEDS ARE LOCATED BUT
BECAUSE OF THE- UNIQUE LOCATION
AT CORCORAN- WHERE WE ACTUALLY
HAD A- GENERAL SHOULD CARE
HOSPITAL CONSTRUCTED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE INSTITUTION- A
BACK ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO-
THERE WERE NO- INDIVIDUAL
EXERCISE YARDS- CONSTRUCTED AT
THAT POINT TIME. SO IN OTHER
LOCATIONS WILL BE A CRISIS BEDS
WE HAVE INDIVIDUAL EXERCISE
YARDS AVAILABLE TO ALLOW OUR A
CRISIS PATIENTS- OUTDOOR
RECREATION THAT DOES NOT EXIST
AT THAT CORE CONSERVATIVE FIXING
A UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE. CAN THANK
YOU SO A JUST A LOT LAST PIECES
GO BACK TO THE- HE THE ISSUE A
HAND- THE CURRENT- STATE
POPULATION IS 910-001-0030 SEVEN
JUST IN THE JUST IN THE
PRESENCE. OF WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
LATEST PROJECTION- FUTURE
PROJECTION OF WHERE HE
POPULATION'S GONNA GO. ANY
PROJECTIONS- IF I REMEMBER OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD THAT WERE
INCLUDED. IN THE JANUARY BUDGET-
SHOW AN INCREASE FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS- AND THEN A
DECREASE IN THE LAST- YEARS OF
THE PROJECTION BUT I DON'T HAVE
THE EXACT NUMBERS IN FRONT OF
THE STORE. GOT ALL JUSTICE LA
OAKS UNDERSTAND BITCOIN HOUSING
FOR. HER YOU KNOW I EIGHT THINK
I LEFT THE PRINTER EARLIER BUT
pAROUND AT NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
OR SO BY THE END OF THE FORECAST
PERIOD SO KIND OF IT WILL GO
IT'S PROJECTED TO GO UP AND
THEN- KIND OF COME BACK DOWN TO
WHERE WE ARE NOW MORE OR LESS BY
THE ASSOCIATED B. L. B. FLAT.
YOUR SIGNAL I MEAN THAT IN THE
LONG OVER THE NEXT FIVE OR SO
YEARS THAT'S WHAT IT SHOWING
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHETHER IT WILL
CONTINUE TO DECLINE AFTER THAT
POINT OR FLATTEN OUT OKAY THEN
THE LAST JUST THE LAST QUESTION
THAT I'M NOT I'M NOT LINE. SO
THEN IN TERMS OF AS YOU LOOKED
OUT- PUT TOGETHER THE LIST OF
PROJECTS THAT EACH OF THE
FACILITIES DID YOU LOOK AT IT
AND START TO- CONSIDER HOW YOU
MIGHT DO- CONSOLIDATION OF YARDS
OR. CONSOLIDATION OF FACILITIES. WELL MY ANSWER WE DID NOT SEE
THAT THE LEVEL OF PROJECTS
NEEDED AT A GIVEN PRISON WAS
SUCH THAT IT- THIS SPOKE TO. THE
NEED TO CONSOLIDATE THOSE
PRESENT THAT PRISON WITH A WITH
ANOTHER PERSON IN MOST OF THESE
CASES THEY WERE INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS NOT PROJECTS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE- OF REQUIRE- ADDED
SIGNIFICANT. CAPITAL OUTLAY-
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FIXES
ACROSS THE ENTIRETY OF THE
PRISON. I GOT AND INSTANCE ARE
SAYING QUESTION I GOT. TO TWO
MORE THIS IS THE SAME QUESTION-
I APOLOGIZE MEDICARE SO- WITH A
WITH A DVR CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH. THE PREVIOUS FIVE YEARS
BEFORE ANNOUNCING THE CLOSURE
WHAT CAPITAL FOR PERSONAL. AS
WELL AS WITH SUSANVILLE. I
CANNOT OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO GET THAT
INFORMATION BACK TO YOU AND THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OKAY GREAT TROUBLE WITH DVI MY
RECOLLECTION WAS THERE WAS A-
KICK FLIP. DON SIMILAR TO YOUR
REQUEST FOR HIS TRIPS AND- THE
HEALTH CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAMS ARE FOR EVERYBODY ELSE-
THERE ARE MY UNDERSTANDING WAS
THERE WAS A HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT ON IT. DVRS
ARE CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT THE
PROJECT WAS COMPLETED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THE INITIATED SOME
ARE AROUND TWENTY TWELVE OR
TWENTY THIRTEEN. GOT AND DID TO
RIP CALL THE ROUGH COST
APPROXIMATELY. MY RECOLLECTION
FROM AROUND THIRTY. THIRTY
MILLION OR SOMETHING I DON'T
KNOW IF ON THE TO THE FROM THE
TOP OF MY HEAD. IT THAT WAS-
SOMETHING CLOSE TO THE FIGURE I
WAS GOING TO PULL OFF THE TOP OF
MIND OKAY GREAT. SO I GUESS WHAT
WHAT WERE THE REASON WE WERE
ASKING YOU THESE QUESTIONS AS WE
DON'T WANT TO BE IN A SITUATION.
WHERE I WAS ON THE- YOU KNOW
WE'RE MOVING IN A IN A GOOD
DIRECTION IN TERMS OF REDUCING
THE POPULATION- WE DON'T REALLY
WANNA BE SPENDING MONEY IN
FACILITIES- AND THEN CLOSING
THOSE FACILITIES. YOU KNOW THAT
ARE. BRAND NEW I GUESS IT'S
SITTING THERE IN A THERE'S A-
PRETTY NICE BRAND NEW HEALTH
CARE FACILITY. AT DVI SO I THINK
THAT IS- THE IMPETUS OF THE OF
THE S. R. L. I WOULD AGREE WITH
WHAT THE HELL ELSE COMMENTS ON-
YOU KNOW WHAT THINK WE MAKE
PRETTY CLEAR IN- PAST HEARINGS
AS WELL AS MEETINGS WITH YOUR
DEPARTMENT. THAT THE- PREVIOUS
REPORT DIDN'T- RESPOND WASN'T
WASN'T COMPLETE WASN'T- FULLY
RESPONSIVE TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND NEITHER I WOULD SAY IS YOUR-
CHARACTERIZATION. SO ON. IT'S
CLEAR THAT IT'S NOT SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE- LOOKING
AT THIS ISSUE THIS YEAR AS WELL
AS IN FUTURE HEARINGS TO.
SABETTA PROCEDURE YOU'RE TIMING
YOUR RESPONSES. THANK YOU- THANK
YOU MISTER KING- FOR YOUR SET OF
QUESTIONS. I JUST I AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE BUT-
MISTER STONE AND I HAD TO
TESTIFY AND I AND I MISS MOST OF
THE DISCUSSION AND SO I DON'T
WANT YOU TO GO OVER IT AGAIN BUT
MAYBE MAYBE I CAN ASK THIS
QUESTION JUST MAYBE IN A
DIFFERENT WAY- WE- WE'VE READ.
FOR AND WE'VE SEEN REPORTS FROM
DIFFERENT FACTIONS THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ASKED. FOR
DIFFERENT INFORMATION- FOR QUITE
SOME TIME- AS BEFORE HAD GRAY
HAIR- THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR
THIS INFORMATION. BUT IT SO KIND
OF THE DIRECTOR OVER GUIDING
PRINCIPLES OF FOR EXAMPLE OF NOT
WASTING TAX PAYERS MONEY BY
DOING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON
BUILDINGS THAT WERE GOING TO
DEMOLISH OR ABANDON OR LEAVE
THEY DID GENERAL- MANAGEMENT OR
FACILITIES MANAGEMENT CONCEPTS.
THAT HAVE BEEN COMING FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AS TO NOT WASTE TAX
PAYERS MONEY. ARE YOU IN
AGREEMENT WITH THAT THE AT LEAST
IN THE GENERAL PRINCIPLES OF
WHAT WE CALL GOOD GOVERNMENT. OF
BECAUSE IT IT BECAUSE WE WERE
FOR A LITTLE PERPLEXED AT WHY IT
TAKES SO LONG. TO GET THIS DONE
WHEN DISK COULD BE SOMETHING.
THAT YOU WOULD BELIEVE WOULD BE
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA AND SO AS AS YOU READ
THROUGH ALL OF THE ANALYSIS AND
EVERYTHING IS DONE. ARE THERE TO
SERVE GENERAL GUIDING PRINCIPLES
THAT YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN YOU
DON'T BELIEVE IN. REDUCING THE
FACILITIES AND IF IT IF IT IF
YOU DON'T DON'T BELIEVE IN IT.
THEN DEFINITELY LET US KNOW IT
MAY BE A VERY GOOD REASON WHY AS
THE PRISON REDUCTION IN NUMBERS
GO DOWN. AND YOU HAVE FEWER
INMATES IN THESE FACILITIES.
THERE'S GOT TO BE REASONS WHY
YOU CAN'T. GIVE US A PLAN FOR
THAT I DO KNOW. IF IT INCREASED
EXPONENTIALLY YOU WOULD BE IN
FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE WANTING
TO BUILD NEW PRISONS JOHNNY ON
THE SPOT ASKING FOR BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SO WHY IS IT
WHEN WE'RE GOING IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION. IT'S SO DIFFICULT. TO
GET CDC ARE TO COOPERATE OR AM I
MISSING SOMETHING. IN YOUR
GENERAL METHODOLOGY- THAT. THAT
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO
GET BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE. WITH
THE ANSWERS THAT WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN WANTING. MONEY SO I'M I'M
GONNA ADD FROM A DIFFERENT MAYBE
ASKING YOU WHY IT'S SO.
DIFFICULT TO GIVE US WHAT WE
WANT AND MAYBE WE CAN HELP YOU
WITH ADDITIONAL MONEY RESOURCES
OR SOMETHING TO GET YOU. THEIR
LIVES- HELP IN OTHER WORDS. HELP
US HELP YOU. THANK THANK YOU SIR
FOR THAT FOR THAT QUESTION- I AM
NOT IN NOT AWARE OF ANYTHING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING- FROM THE LEGISLATURE
FOR ASSISTANCE IN IN THESE
DEISIONS- I AM A I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD WANT ARE YOU SAYING THAT-
DON'T IS THAT THAT. THIS
COMMITTEE IS ASKS FOR ANYTHING
ON THE OTHER STRUCTURE YOUR YOUR
QUESTION OF HELP YOU'RE YOUR
YOUR YOUR COMEDY- YOU KNOW IT
HELP IT HELP YOU HELP US I WANT
TO WAKE THE WANTED TO SAVE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS- OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED THE REDUCING OUR
POPULATION- THAT- HAS LED- TWO
DECISIONS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
AND IN CONCERT WITH
ADMINISTRATION- FOR THE CLOSURE
OF PRISONS THAT WORLD AGREE TO
AND- TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT-
AND SO THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUES
TO REVIEW THE FACTORS- THAT ARE
PRESENT REGARDING POPULATION
PROJECTIONS A PROJECT A
SUBPOPULATION NEEDS AND ALL THE
ABOVE TO- E. VALUATE- THE
POTENTIAL FOR ADDITIONAL
CULTURES. I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
IS- THAT THAT ACT CERTAINLY IF
IT'S NOT MY POSITION TO GIVE MY
OPINION I'M TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT AGAINST- WHAT
THE POPULATION PROJECTIONS MAY
SHOW- WOULD BE A NEED FOR FUTURE
FUTURE CLOSURES. I JUST THINK
THAT THE- PATHWAY TO GET THERE-
REQUIRED A LOT OF DECISIONS ON
DEPARTMENT- THAT REQUIRE. GOOD
INFORMATION AND THAT INFORMATION
TO BE AVAILABLE. AT THE RIGHT
TIME- AND SO. WE GET BACK TO
WINNING ORIGINAL POINTS OF YOUR
DELIVERY OF NOT SPENDING MONEY
AT PRISONS- MORE THERE'S A HIGH
LIKELIHOOD OF CLOSING I THINK
THAT- DEPARTMENT WOULD NOT BE IN
A POSITION TO SAY THAT WE
DISAGREE WITH THAT I THINK IT'S
A QUESTION OF BEING ABLE TO. GET
INFORMATION TOGETHER THAT ALLOWS
ONE TO SEE- WHAT THE FUTURE'S
GOING TO HOLD AND BE ABLE TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS IN A MANNER
THAT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONTINUE TO MEET ITS MISSION- AT
ITS FACILITIES- IT BECAUSE AS
LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE
AND HAVE INCARCERATED POPULATION
AT THE FACILITY WE NEED TO MEET
OUR PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS. THAT
REQUIRES SOME LEVEL OF- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND IN CAPITAL
OUTLAY- SO I GUESS I DON'T SEE-THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS BEING. IN A
POSITION OF TIME METRICALLY
OPPOSED- I THINK THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED THAT HASN'T BEEN
AVAILABLE YET. AND THAT THE
SIDES ARE NOT THAT FAR APART AS
FAR AS BEING ABLE TO- REACHED
CERTAIN CUT A CERTAIN DECISIONS.
REGARDING FUTURE OPERATIONS
PERSONS. BUT ISN'T IT TRUE. THAT
THERE WAS A LAWSUIT SAYING THAT
CDC ARE. REASON FOR STALLING OR
INHIBITING OUR ABILITY TO CLOSE
IS BECAUSE OF THE LOSSES IN A WE
HAD NOT COME OVER TO ADEQUATELY
PLAN. A PLAN THAT I BELIEVE
NEEDS TO COME FROM. C. D. C. R.
AND IF YOU CAN'T COME UP WITH
IT. IT INHIBITS OUR ABILITY. TO
SAVE TAXPAYER MONEY IN CLOSING
THESE FACILITIES. AND OBVIOUSLY
IN A SAFE EFFICIENT AND
EQUITABLE MANNER SO WHAT I'M- IT
SOUNDS LIKE. YOU HAVE NOT. IT OR
CDCR HAS NOT COME ON BOARD WITH
THIS CONCEPT OF CONSOLIDATION OR
- DOING SOME SOME- RIGHT SIZING
SO THAT WE CAN CREATE THE BEST
OPTIMAL. BOB POSITION TO PUT
EVERYBODY IN A IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME SAVING TAXPAYERS MONEY THE
SAID IT FEELS LIKE YOU HAVEN'T.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT AS A WHOLE
HAS NOT COME TO GRIPS WITH IT
AND I'VE WRAPPED THEIR ARMS
AROUND IT DID NOT FULLY. KIND
OF- ACCEPTED THAT THIS IS THE
WAY. AS YOU SAID THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE GOVERNOR
MAY WANT AND I WOULD IMAGINE IF
WE WERE TO DO A POLL WHEN I KNOW
POLLS AREN'T EXACT REFERRED TO A
POLE WITH TAXPAYERS THEY WOULD
SAY. THEY AGREE WITH THE
APPROACH. THAT THE LEGISLATURE
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. IT'S
TAKING RIGHT NOW HOWEVER CDC ARE
MAY NOT REALLY BE ON BOARD WITH
THIS JUST YET IT. THIS THIS IS
DISCOUNTED APPEALING WE'RE
GETTING. I WOULD I WOULDN'T I
WOULD NEVER I CANNOT AGREE THAT
THE- DEPARTMENT IS NOT IN THE
SAME POSITION AS FAR AS THE
GOVERNOR'S CONCERNED BECAUSE
WE'RE PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION
SO ALL I CAN. SPEAK TO IS WE'RE
- TESTIFYING TODAY BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT WE PROVIDED
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT
WAS IN THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET BUT
WE ALSO IS THAT THAT TIS IS
WHERE THINGS ARE NOW BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE ARE STILL
LOOKING AND EVALUATING THE NEEDS
OF FOR THE FUTURE- THAT MAY BE
DISCUSSED IN AND- WHEN BETTER.
ONE BETTER OR MORE CLEAR
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE. AND
WHEN WILL THAT BE ABOUT MAYBE
AND GO THAT WAY HOPE IS JUST
ANOTHER. YOU KNOW I TERM OUT IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR YOU HAVE AND
WHAT TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I MEAN
I. I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING. HOW
WHY DID IT TAKE SO LONG WELL
WHAT WHAT CAN WE GET THIS
INFORMATION. I DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC TIME FRAME TO PROVIDE
YOU BECAUSE IT'S AN ONGOING
INTERVIEW PROCESS I THINK TO
PLEASE ALL THE REFERENCE TO PM
LEE AND MY REGIONAL. JUST TALKED
TO WHOMEVER YOU NEED TO TALK TO.
AND MAYBE GET BACK TO THE CHAIR.
I'M PRETTY SURE IT THE CHAIR
WOULD BE VERY INTERESTED. IN
BRINGING. IN THIS WHOLE
DISCUSSION TO A TO SOME KIND OF
CLOSE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. I
WILL I WILL I HAVE A SET OF
ACTIONS TO I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR QUESTIONS
AND FOR REMINDING. CDC ARE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION THAT WE GET TO BE
PART OF THE DISCUSSION IN THIS
AS WELL- WHEN IT I WON ACTUALLY
PIGGY BACK TO MISTER JOHN
SERVICE QUESTION AND SO DO WE
HAVE. DO WE HAVE ADEQUATE-
PROJECTIONS. ABOUT PRISON
POPULATION AT THIS POINT CAN YOU
UGB WE HAVE ADEQUATE PROJECTIONS
THIS IS FOR CDC ARE. OTHER
THINGS THAT THEY JUST NEED A
MINUTE BERMAN A FINANCE I CAN
SPEAK TO THE PROJECTIONS FOR THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS I DO JUST WANT
TO KNOW AS THAT MR NEIL
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT WE'RE
PROJECTING RIGHT NOW AN INCREASE
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS-
FOR VARIOUS COVERED RELATED
REASONS AND BECAUSE OF BACKLOGS-
IN AND TO ABOUT LEVEL OUT AROUND
A HUNDRED THOUSAND. I DO WANT TO
NOTE THOUGH THAT YOU KNOW OUR
PROJECTIONS ARE GENERALLY REALLY
GOOD WITHIN A COUPLE OF
PERCENTAGE POINTS WITHIN THE
NEXT YEAR OR TWO BUT THE FURTHER
OUT YOU GET- THE MUCH IT BECOMES
MUCH HARDER TO KIND OF PROJECT
WHERE THE POPULATION WILL BE.
I'M JUST FOR REFERENCE ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO THE POPULATION WAS AT
ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
AND OUR AT ABOUT NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND SO I THINK IT IT JUST
KIND OF INDICATES KIND OF
SIGNIFICANT SHIFTS THAT CAN
OCCUR UP OR DOWN AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S DIFFICULT TO KIND OF DO
THIS KIND OF LONG TERM PLANNING.
WHEN THE PROJECT WAS IN OUR EARS
CAN BE SO VARIABLE JUST TO BE
CLEAR YOU'RE TELLING ME YOU DO
NOT HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN THE
PROJECTIONS THAT CDC ARE PUT ON
BE ON THE NEXT TWO YEARS AND
THAT THE FACT THAT WHAT THEY'RE
PROJECTING 4% DECLINE POPULATION
DECLINE. IS THAT WAY TO SET.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH THAT WE DON'T
HAVE. FAITH IN THEM JUST THAT
THEY CAN SWING YOU KNOW TEN OR DEPENDING ON. VARIOUS
ACTIONS WE WEREN'T ANTICIPATING
KOBE AND THAT POPULATION CAN
SWING PRETTY DRAMATICALLY
BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF. OUTSIDE
FACTORS. AND SO IT BECOMES
DIFFICULT TO SAVE IT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO. THIS SORT
OF FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
BECAUSE OF PROJECTION BETTER
FIVE TEN YEARS OUT. BUT YOUR
PROJECTIONS ARE NOT ACTUALLY
TENURE SOUTH THAT YOU THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT HERE TODAY THERE
ARE ABOUT THREE TO FOUR MAYBE
FIVE YEARS SO IT'S ACTUALLY A
PRETTY SHORT TERM. WE PASSED
LEGISLATION ON A REGULAR BASIS
PROJECTING FOR EXAMPLE I WORK A
LOT IN THE CLIMATE CHANGE SPACE
AND WE'VE BEEN PROJECTING
TOWARDS TWENTY THIRTY AND WE
FELT CONFIDENCE IN THAT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. SO UNDERSTAND
HOW. HOW YOU DON'T HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE PROJECTIONS
THAT CDC ARE PROVIDED FOR THE
NEXT FOUR TO FIVE YEARS. TO HELP
US. OUT TO USE THAT. IN COMING
UP WITH THE LIST OR
INFRASTRUCTURE OUT CAPITAL
OUTLAY. IN A INVESTOR P. A. S.
BILL WITH ITS PROVIDED AS PART
OF THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTIONS GO OUT ABOUT TEN
YEARS. AND THOSE ARE CONJECTURAL
AND CONCEPTUAL PROJECTS THAT
WERE PROJECTING UP TO ABOUT TEN
YEARS. BUT AS MR FORGET MENTION
AS PART OF THE DELIVERED OF
BUDGET PROCESS EVERY YEAR WE
KIND OF ANALYZE AND ASSESS THAT
MOST URGENT FIRE LIFE SAFETY
NEEDS ARE. COURT MANDATED NEED
TO AND WE PROJECT THAT WAS AND
INCLUDE THOSE IN THE BUDGET AND-
DISCUSS WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
ON WHAT FUND. SO I'M I'M HAPPY
ABOUT IT THE COURT MANDATES. THE
DEPARTMENT EITHER HERE BECAUSE
WE HAVE FAILED AGAIN- ONE OR
ANOTHER AND SO. WHEN IT SEPARATE
THOSE FROM THE DISCUSSION FOR A
SECOND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE COMPLYING WITH THE
COURT'S- WE HAVE MADE. WE SEE
THE PRISON POPULATION DECLINING.
YET WE SEE THE BUDGET FOR THIS
DEPARTMENT INCREASING- OUT. FROM
THE SET OF QUESTIONS WE'VE
GOTTEN FROM MY COLLEAGUES HERE
WE DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW YOU'RE
PRIORITIZING AND WE DON'T HAVE
FAITH THAT. WE'RE SPENDING
DOLLARS A PROBABLY VOTE BOTH
BOTH FOR. THINGS LIKE SAFETY BUT
ALSO PROJECT TEAM. THE TYPES OF
CULTURAL SHIFTS THAT WE WANT TO
SEE IF THERE ARE POLICIES AND IN
OUR PRISON SYSTEM. WHAT OUT
THERE AND SO HOW DO YOU BEST.
HOW DO YOU BEST- PROPOSE WE GET
PROJECTIONS ARE WE GET A LIST
THAT STARTS TO TAKE INTO THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION THINGS THAT
POPULATION DECREASING PRESENTS
CLOSE SEEN. CHANGING OUR
APPROACH TO REHABILITATION. HOW
DO YOU BEST THANK WEEK WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO GET. THAT MATRIX
SERVING A FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD FROM CDC I THE
ADMINISTRATION. WHICH IS WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR MANY YEARS
. SO WE CAN GIVE YOU MONEY WANT
TO SPEND MONEY TO WE JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE IT IN A SMART WAY.
AT THE END ENSURE THINK THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION ONE OF THE
THINGS. THAT WE HAVE BEEN
INVESTING AND REGULATED
ADMINISTRATION APARTMENT HAS
BEEN THINGS LIKE HEALTHCARE
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES. HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THIS YEAR TO KIND OF
INCREASE- YOU KNOW CAN BE A
COLLEGE ACCESS FOR. INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS SO A LOTOF THE
BUDGET INCREASES IN THE MOST
RECENT YEARS HAVE BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH THINGS LIKE
HEALTH CARE- OR EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND- AND LIKE YOU
MENTIONED IT IS KIND OF A SHIFT
IN. HOW WE'RE TREATING
INCARCERATED POPULATIONS- AS FAR
AS- INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
AGAIN WE- WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE I'M KIND
OF. YOU KNOW GETTING TO THE
RIGHT POINT BUT WE THINK THAT.
WHAT WE PUT FORWARD IS BEING.
RESPONSIVE TO THE EXTENT THAT
WERE AGAIN KIND OF LISTING WHAT
PROJECTS WERE PROJECTING RIGHT
NOW- AT THIS POINT IN TIME FOR
THE NEXT. DECADE OR SO YOUR LAST
NAME AND WITH THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH. THE
LEGISLATURE- IT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN- THIS DISCUSSION.
STARTED OF VERY SPECIFICALLY AND
LAST YEAR WE PUT SOME VERY
SPECIFIC STRUCTURE INTO THE TYPE
OF INFORMATION WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE WHAT THIS PLANNING. BUT THAT
HASN'T THAT'S NOT WHAT WE GOT.
IN THIS PROPOSAL SO IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT THAT'S A- TRUE
STATEMENT AT LEAST FROM ACTION
VERSES WORDS THUS FAR- ARE THERE
WAYS THAT YOU'LL AT CDCR IS
WORKING TO REDUCE THEIR BUDGET.
ABSOLUTELY AGAIN JUST TO
REITERATE THAT WE HAVE YOU KNOW
PROPOSED Q. PRISON CLOSURES
COMPLETELY IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE
ALSO COMPLETELY ELIMINATED
CONTRACTS THAT WE PREVIOUSLY HAD
WITH OUT OF STATE AND IN STATE
CONTRACTED CITIES- SO AT THE
POPULATION HAS COME DOWN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN PRO
ACTIVELY WORKING ON RIGHT
SIZING. THAT PRISON SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE PROPOSAL WE
HAVE BEFORE US ARE ACTUALLY JUST
CONTINUE TO INCREASE. THE COST
AND NOT DECREASE THE COST SO CAN
YOU EXPLAIN TO ME THAT
DISCREPANCY. I THINK THEY'RE
DIFFERENT- PROPOSALS THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY AND IN
THE ENGINE BAY AS MR VARGAS
STATED URBAN PARTLY BASED ON
FIRE LIKE SAFETY- KIND OF OTHER
URGENT INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS-
CONCURRENTLY WE'VE ALSO BEEN
DOING OTHER WORK TO CLOSE-
INSTITUTIONS. THE I. C. C. R.
REDUCE THEIR BUDGET BY ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THROUGH THE CLOSURE OF I
DO OCCASIONALLY TO DETECTION SO.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THAT THESE
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU ARE
REDUCTIONS IN COST BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN OTHER REDUCTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH DECLINES IN
POPULATION. DO YOU- DO YOU
UNDERSTAND OUR FRUSTRATION AT
THIS POINT AS WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THE S. R. ALLEN- THE
LANGUAGE YOU PUT INTO LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET TO MAKE IT CLEAR.
THE TYPE OF INFORMATION WE GOT
BRACES WHICH PROVIDED FOR US THE
WAY WE KEEP RUNNING IN CIRCLES
FOR THE LAST HOUR PLUS HEARING
COMMITTEE. I DO UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION AND KIND OF THE PUSH
PULL OF IT I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING IF IT IS
A VERY DIFFICULT TO KIND OF
PROJECT OUT HERE WHO NEEDS TO
KNOW. IF THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
STORM THAT HAD OCCURRED I THINK.
SIX YEARS AGO OR SO THEY KIND OF
STARTED THE ROOF INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROJECTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
PROPOSING EVERY YEAR- YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANT WEATHER EVENTS
SOMETHING LIKE AN EARTHQUAKE
SOMETHING UNPREDICTABLE MIGHT
OCCUR AND THAT WOULD TOP OFF OUR
OUR CURRENT PROJECTIONS IT WHICH
IS WHY WHEN WE'RE DOING KIND OF
DELIBERATE BUDGET PROCESS EVERY
YEAR. WE PROJECT WHAT WE NEED AT
THAT TIME. THE URGENT ISSUES
THAT THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE I'M
I'VE ONLY BEEN HERE TEN YEARS I
HAVEN'T BEEN HERE YOU KNOW- FOR
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA BUT
IN. MY TEN YEARS HERE WE
DEFINITELY PLAN AHEAD AND WE
PLAN AHEAD INCLUDING THINKING
ABOUT. EMERGENCIES WHETHER
THAT'S AN EARTHQUAKE- WHETHER
THAT'S CLIMATE CHANGE. WEATHER
NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE PLANNING BETTER
FOR. THE NEXT SEARCHING COLLATOR
. THE NEXT YOU KNOW- A MEDICAL
HEALTH SHOULD HAVE HERE- SO. I
DON'T UNDERSTAND IT FEELS LIKE
YOU'RE CHANGING THE RULES OF THE
GAME ON US TO FOR. TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE A BLOATED BUDGET WHEN WE
SEEM TO MEAN FOR DICK DECLINING
POPULATIONS. SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN
TO ME THE DISCREPANCY THERE Y.
SEEMS TO WORK IN SOME CASES BUT
NOT OTHERS NOT NOT IN THIS CASE
. I'M NOT SURE WITHOUT LOOKING
REALLY SPECIFICALLY A CERTAIN
BUDGET LINE ITEMS YOU KNOW ON
SAY WHAT THE FACILITY COSTS HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY VERSUS OVERALL
COSTS BUT AGAIN I THINK THAT.
THE EMPHASIS ON INCREASING COSTS
HAVE LARGELY BEEN ASSOCIATED
WITH HEALTH CARE AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL OR COURT
ORDERED MANDATE SO. AGAIN I AM
NOT SURE THAT WE CAN MAKE A
COMPARISON ON THE OVERALL
DEPARTMENT BUDGET COMPARED TO
SPECIFIC ISSUES RELATED TO
INFRASTRUCTURE OR FACILITIES.
ARE YOU COMMITTED IT ARE YOU
COMMITTED TO THERE ACTUALLY
BEING A CHANGER WE JUST TRYING
TO. RUN THE CLOCK ON US BEING
HERE IS THAT THE BUSINESS AS
USUAL CAN CONTINUE. WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO WORKING
FOR HIM LIKE I SAID RIGHT SIZING
THE PRISON POPULATION AND THE
NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS AND
FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE SO WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY AWARE OF BEING
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE. THANKS ARE
GIVEN THAT COMMITMENT THAT YOU
JUST REITERATED TO ALL OF US I
THINK IT WOULD BE PRUDENT FOR
YOU TO TAKE. THEIR VEGAS
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ABOUT A
MATRIX OF HIGHER MAKING DECISION
THE- FEDERAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
AND THE BUDGET AND WHEN YOU COME
BACK TO US- PERCENT- INFORMATION
A SEARCH TO ANSWER OUR-
QUESTIONS THAT THIS ACTUALLY
FEELS LIKE A PARTNERSHIP- AND
THE COMMITMENT FEELS. TRUE AS
WELL. AND SO ALL RIGHT PLEASE
TAKE OUR QUESTIONS AS CLEAR THE
SATISFACTION AS THE TEACHER I
WOULD SAY AT THIS. ASSIGNMENT IS
NOT JUST A COMPLETE BUT
MISINTERPRETED AND ENCOURAGE YOU
TO QUICKLY INTERPRETED HOW TO DO
IT PROPERLY AND THAT MR JONES
SAWYER SIR WE ARE HERE TO HELP
YOU SEE IF YOU NEED US HELP TO
CLARIFY WHAT THAT MIGHT LOOK
LIKE- MORE THAN WILLING TO DO
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO GONNA GO
AHEAD AND- CLOSE OFF THIS
DISCUSSION FOR TODAY I WILL
REVISIT AGAIN WHEN I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES ARE GOING TO WANT TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND TAMMY IRWIN I MEAN I
TEAM MANAGER TO AT CBC ARTS
ENTERPRISE INFORMATION SERVICES.
FIFTY FIFTY PROVIDE SPENDING AND
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
STATEWIDE EXPANSION AND UPGRADE
OF THE MANAGED ACCESS SYSTEMS.
MANAGE ACCESS IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
CONTRABAND CELLULAR PHONE
INTERDICTION STRATEGY AND IT'S
DESIGNED TO DISRUPT CONTRABAND
PHONE COMMUNICATIONS ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT TO INTERFERE WITH AND
DISMANTLE CONTRABAND
DISTRIBUTION CHANNELS.
CONTRABAND DIRECTLY IMPACTS THE
SAFETY AND OF THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION. STAFF AND THE PUBLIC
. THE CONTRA HAS ALSO BEEN A
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES INCLUDING
VICTIMIZATION CITIZENS
POSSIBILITIES WITHIN THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION I DIDN'T
RISK OVERDOSE AND THE
INTERFERENCE WITH AN ENVIRONMENT
CONDUCIVE TO A SUCCESSFUL
REHABILITATION. CONTRABAND
CELLPHONES DELIVER A LINK
BETWEEN INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
AND OUTSIDE ACTORS ENABLING THE
CONTINUOUS OPERATION OF
CONTRABAND DISTRIBUTION NETWORKS
AND OTHER CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES.
CDC ARE PROPOSES THE UPGRADE OF
THE MANAGED ACCESS SYSTEMS AT
THE EIGHTEEN FIFTIES AREN'T
SITUATIONS WHERE IT CURRENTLY
EXISTS AND EXPANSION OF THE
INVOLVED TECHNOLOGY TO THE
REMAINING ADULT INSTITUTIONS.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR JARED LEVINE OUT
FROM THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS AND I. ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
CAITLIN O'NEILL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE
THINK THAT THE IDEA OF
INSTALLING NEW CELLPHONE
INTERDICTION TECHNOLOGY. THAT
NOT ON. NOW WITH. IT WAS THE ONE
THAT WAS ON. THEFT PARKING.
CAITLIN O'NEILL AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
FIND THAT THE IDEA OF INSTALLING
NEW CELLPHONE INTERDICTION
TECHNOLOGY AT PRISONS APPEARS
REASONABLE AS IT COULD HELP
REDUCE CRIME BOTH INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF PRISON. HOWEVER WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AS CURRENTLY STRUCTURED
COULD RESULT IN THE INFLATION OF
THE TECHNOLOGY AT PRISONS THAT
ARE CLOSE SHORTLY THEREAFTER.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE UNDER THE
PROPOSAL CDCR WOULD RECEIVE
FUNDING TO INSTALL THE
TECHNOLOGY AT- ALL THREE OF ITS
STATE OWNED AND CURRENTLY
OPERATED PRISONS- YET AS WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER THE STATE THE
POPULATION DECLINE- SUGGESTS
THAT THE STATE COULD BE AN- A
POSITION TO CLOSE AROUND FIVE
PRISONS. OVER THAT SAME TIME
PERIOD THAT BEAT TECHNOLOGY
WOULD BE ROLLED OUT UNDER THE
PROPOSAL. A ROUGHLY AROUND THE
SAME TIME PERIOD. I'M SO TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF INSTALLING
CELLPHONE INTERDICTION
TECHNOLOGY AT PRISONS THAT ARE
SUBSEQUENTLY CLOSE WE RECOMMEND
ONE. PROVIDING FUNDING ONLY FOR
A PUT A PORTION OF THE PRISONS.
AND TO ENSURING THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS ONLY INSTALLED AT
PRISONS THAT ARE NOT STRONG
CANDIDATES FORECLOSURE. AND SAYS
PACIFIC WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IMPROVE APPROVE ONLY
FUNDING FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS
AS LAID OUT IN THE PROPOSALS SO
THAT WOULD INCLUDE EIGHT.
PRISONS IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
TWELVE PRISONS IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR- AND REJECT
FOR NOW THE REMAINING PRESENTS.
AND THEN SECOND BEFORE-
PROVIDING THE FUNDING WE
RECOMMEND DIRECTING CDCR TO
PROVIDE A LIST OF WHAT TURNED
TWENTY PRESENT IT WOULD INSTALL
THE TECHNOLOGY AT- SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THAT LIST DOESN'T- THAT LIST
ONLY INCLUDES PRISONS THAT ARE
NOT STRONG CANDIDATES FOR
CLOSURE. AND THAT I GENERALLY
NEED PRISONS THAT PROVIDE A
CENTRAL OR PURCHASING A
SPECIALIZED HEALTHCARE SERVICES
OR- ARE CAPABLE OF HOUSING
INMATES WITH A WIDE VARIETY OF
CLASSIFICATIONS OF SECURITY
CLASSIFICATIONS XCERRA. AND OF
COURSE EASIER COULD COME BACK
AND REQUEST. FUNDING FOR THE
REMAINING PRESENT IN THE FUTURE
WHEN THAT THERE'S A CLEAR SENSE
OF WHAT- AND HOW MANY PRISONS
WOULD BE WILL BE ULTIMATELY
CLOSED. I ALSO KNOW THAT TAKING
THE STAGE APPROACH TO FUNDING
THE TECH THE EXPANSION OF THE
TECHNOLOGY COULD ALSO IMPROVE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. OF ITS
ROLLOUT- TO ENSURE THAT SAID
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY AND CONSISTENT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES.
THANK YOU. HI AND LENITION
MATTER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AT
THIS TIME THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
NOT IDENTIFIED ANY ADDITIONAL
CLOSURES AS AS WE'VE DISCUSSED-
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN STATE INSTITUTIONS TO
PROVIDE A SAFE AND SECURE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION STAFF AND THE
COMMUNITY. I WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE IS CONSIDERABLE
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS PROPOSAL DUE
TO THE FACT THAT IT IS A MULTI
YEAR ROLLOUT SHOULD A PERSON BE
IDENTIFIED FOR CLOSURE AFTER THE
EQUIPMENT HAS ALREADY BEEN
INSTALLED THE EQUIPMENT CAN BE
RELOCATED TO ANOTHER PERSON- IF
THE NEW EQUIPMENT HAS YET TO BE
INSTALLED THE FUNDING ASSOCIATED
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ENHANCED CELLULAR INTERDICTION
WILL BE RETURNED TO THE GENERAL
FUND THROUGH THE BUDGETING
PROCESS WHEN CLOSING THAT PERSON
. I READ JUST REITERATE TO THE
SUB COMMITTEE THAT ENHANCE
CELLULAR INTERDICTION IT'S AN
IMPORTANT SAFETY MEASURE TO
DISABLE THE ILLEGAL USE OF
CELLPHONES. WITHIN THE PRISONS
THAT THEY CAN BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE SKIPS GANG ACTIVITY
NARCOTICS DISTRIBUTION AS WELL
AS VIOLENCE AGAINST OTHER
INCARCERATED PEOPLE. STAFF AND
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY THANK
YOU. SO GIVEN. I WOULD SAY THIS-
GIVEN GIVEN THAT IT'S NOT WE
DON'T HAVE A CLEAR LONG TERM.
PLAN FOR PRESSING CLOSER SEVEN
OTHERS COMMITMENTS FOR THAT- CAN
THE CDC ARE OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SPEAK TO L. A. O.'S
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE DO THIS
IN STAGGERING. PROCESS. SURE AS%
I SAID I BELIEVE IT IS SOMEWHAT
OF A STACK OF PROCESS ALREADY
BECAUSE IT ROLLS OUT OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS- SHOULD AS PRISON
ALTERNATELY DECIDE. HE DECIDED A
CULTURE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE CAN
BE MOVED TO A DIFFERENT PRISON
OR IF THAT PERSON HAS NOT
RECEIVED INSTALLATION OF THAT
YET THAT FUNDING WOULD BE
RETURNED TO THE GENERAL FUND
ASSOCIATIVE THAT PRISON'S
CLOSURE. BUT IF WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE A
STAGGERED PROCESS WHERE WE
ASKING FOR ALL THE MONEY UP
FRONT AND NOT BUDGETING THAT IN
A STANDARD WAY. I BELIEVE. MANY
PROPOSALS ARE OFTEN DONE IN A
MULTIPLE YEAR ROLLOUT PHASE
THAT'S JUST HOW THE EQUIPMENT
WILL BE INSTALLED ON THIS ONE
SURE THAT ALL PRISONERS RECEIVE.
THE SECURITY MEASURES NEEDED.
BUT DO WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
IT'S NOT OFFICES BUT IF I SEE
OUR PRESENCE THAT WILL REMAIN.
OPEN. I CANNOT FUNDING COULD BE.
TAKEN DOWN WHEN THEY'RE IF A
PRISON CLOSURES ALTERNATELY
DECIDED. BUT THAT DOESN'T-ACCOUNT FOR WHERE YOU TO SOME OF
THAT IN SOME PRISONS. WE MIGHT
INSTALLED. WE MIGHT INSTALL THE
EQUIPMENT AND THEN AFTER THE
MATTER. CHOOSE TO CLOSE ON THE
PERSON. SO THAT WOULD STILL HAVE
AN CRITICS SPENCER THEM WITH
UNNECESSARY. I'M NOT EQUIPMENT
COULD BE REPURPOSED AND MOVE TO
ANOTHER INSTITUTION- IT'S STILL
THE TECHNOLOGY IS EVOLVING FOR.
FURTHER TESTS- AND WE THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THE
SECURITY OF THE PRISONS BY
DISABLING THOSE ILLEGAL
CELLPHONES. SO WE AGREE THAT
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT. ITEM
TO INVEST AND WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE INVESTING IN IT AND
IN A THOUGHTFUL MANNER. AND IF
THIS IS GOING TO BE. SPREAD OUT
OVER TIME IT MIGHT MAKE MORE
SENSE THAT AS WE GET INFORMATION
WE- ALLOCATE MONIES IN THE
FUTURE AND NOT. NOW THAT WE
MIGHT ENCOURAGE SOME UNNECESSARY
SPENDING. DO MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM.
MISTER JONES SAWYER AND
ASSERTING. I LARA AYE I THINK
WE'RE ALL IN FAVOR OF THIS BUT
THE SECULAR INTERDICTION
TECHNOLOGY I DON'T THINK YOU'LL
FIND ANYONE THAT THAT'S AGAINST
IT AD IN FACT- WE PROBABLY
SHOULD FIGURE OUT A WAY. WE CAN
TEST ITS ACCOUNTABILITY IS
RELIABILITY IS EFFECTIVENESS
WHETHER THAT'S THE NUMBER OF-
CONTRABAND AT STATE SEIZE WHILE
YOU HAVE IT THEIR NUMBER FONG
CELLPHONES THEY RECEIVED IT CAN
WE LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF-
VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENS. IN PRISON
DOESN'T GO DOWN AS A RESULT OF
PUTTING NEEDS IN IT ISN'T
TANGIBLE THINGS THAT WE CAN TEST
YOUR COME BACK. TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND ITS BASIC SAY
SINCE WE PUT. THIS TECHNOLOGY
IMPRISONED HEY. IT'S IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE IS IMPROVE THE
SAFETY OF INMATES AND GUARDS-
PROPORTIONALLY BY X. AMOUNT AND
THIS IS WHY THIS IS A GREAT NOT
A GOOD AND- TECHNOLOGY PRODUCES
GREAT TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
BENEFICIAL. TO THE- TO CDC ARE
AS A WHOLE I THINK YOU MAY BE ON
TO SOMETHING THAT COULD BE VERY
VERY HELPFUL AND- IF YOU'RE ABLE
TO CAPTURE ITS BENEFITS OF
ULTIMATELY- IT NOT ONLY WOULD IT
SPREAD TO THE OTHER PRISONS. BUT
AS NEW TECHNOLOGY COMES OUT
BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW-
CRIMINALS ARE VERY SMART NO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET AROUND
THIS WE MAY HAVE TO BUY
SOMETHING A LITTLE MORE
SOPHISTICATED. WILL INVEST THAT
BECAUSE WE NOW HAVE THE DATA
THAT SHOWS THAT THIS TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY. IS THE BEST THING
FOR A- FOR OUR PRISON POPULATION
AND THE PRISON GUARDS SO IS
THERE ANY WAY YOU COULD. COME UP
WITH WITH THE ALGORITHM OR- SOME
KIND OF CODE THAT CAN SHOW US
HOW EFFECTIVE. USE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY COULD BE. OR IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU GOT TO COME BACK
TO US WITH. HELLO I BELIEVE THAT
WE WOULD NEED TO COME BACK TO
YOU THERE ARE SEVERAL MITIGATING
FACTORS AT THAT WAY INTO WHAT
AND CHANGES THE BEHAVIOR AND THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE PRESENT-
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT- THAT
BLOCKING A CELL PHONES AND
INTERDICTING. CONTRABAND FROM
COMING INTO THE PRESENCE IS OVER
ALL AND VERY BENEFICIAL TO THE
DEPARTMENT- BUT WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT- WAYS OF COLLECTING
THAT DATA- EVEN MORE THAN WE
ALREADY DO. TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
THAT BACK WITH ME WITH THE
ASSEMBLY. CAN YOU GIVE US LIKE
AN OUTLINE OF WHAT THAT COULD
POSSIBLY LOOK AT LIKE AS YOU. AS
YOU COME BACK TO IT AGAIN FOUR
FOUR ESPECIALLY TO DO THIS IN A
TIERED STAGGERED MANNER THAT YOU
CAN COME BACK IN. AND THEY
REALLY HAVE SOME GOOD DATA OF
WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT- A MAN
I HAVE SO MUCH FAITH IN IT THAT
I KNOW TO COME. IF YOU IF YOU
ANALYZE IT UP FRONT. ONE DISK
COMMITTEE IN AND- WILL
OVERWHELMINGLY BE IN FAVOR OF
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM. I DO KNOW
THAT WE ARE ALREADY TRACKING-
AND- A LOT AROUND THE
CONFISCATED CELLPHONES AND
CONFISCATED- OTHER CONTENT FROM
THE CONTRABAND- BUT I DO THINK
THAT WE COULD- PULL THEM
TOGETHER STEM AND YEAH-
MEASUREMENTS. SOME METRICS THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO- BASELINE AND
THEN BRING BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE- WHEN WE CAN SHOW-
WHAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS REALLY
DOING ESPECIALLY AFTER IT'S BEEN
UPGRADED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEASURES JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
WHAT WE MEASURE WAS TALKING
ABOUT SO- I GUESS WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT I HEARD FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WAS THAT- THEY WANT TO
HAVE A MULTI YEAR APPROACH
BECAUSE- THEY HAVE A MULTI YEAR
PLAN ON THIS PROPOSAL BUT WHAT
WE HEARD FROM THE- FOR MISTER
BORK IS THAT EVERYTHING IS DONE
YEAR TO YEAR WITH ALL THE
FACILITIES PLANNING SO WHICH-
SOME CONFUSED WHICH ONE IS IT.
WE CAN PLAN OUR WE DO EVERYTHING
YEAR TO YEAR. BECAUSE WE'RE GOOD
WE WERE HEARING DIFFERENT THINGS
FROM. DIFFERENT FACTIONS IN THE
DEPARTMENT. LET ME SHATTER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO ALL THE
INSTITUTIONS AND REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE KEEPING PACE
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY OUT WE FEEL
<c.red>T'S IMPORTANT TO. SECURING THE</c>
FUNDING FOR ALL INSTITUTIONS
NOW- WELL FUNDING ISN'T
AVAILABLE TO EXPAND TO ALL
INSTITUTIONS AND WE DON'T WANT
TO GET IN A POSITION WHERE A FEW
YEARS DOWN THE LINE WE DON'T
HAVE AS MUCH. AVAILABLE FUNDING
AND WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS ADDITIONAL SECURITY
AT ALL INSTITUTIONS. OKAY BUT
HOW THE HOW HOW ARE YOU ABLE TO
DETERMINE THAT EVERY FOR EVERY.
FACILITY NEEDS THIS TECHNOLOGY
WHEN YOU CAN DETERMINE THE
PREVIOUS ITEM- WHAT ITEMS WHICH
ITEMS NEED IMPROVING AT
DIFFERENT FACILITIES. SOME OF
THE INSTITUTIONS DON'T HVE BEST
MANAGE ACCESS OUR SYSTEM
TECHNOLOGY IT ALSO CURRENTLY
EIGHTEEN OF THE INSTITUTIONS
HAVE SOME LEVEL OF THIS SECURITY
HOWEVER IT'S NOT- HOW DOUBLE AT
FIVE G. TECHNOLOGY SO THIS IS
REALLY TO EXPAND TO THOSE
INSTITUTIONS THAT DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE THIS AVAILABLE.
AND KEEP PACE WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S EVOLVING- WE
DON'T WHAT WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THAT WE REALLY CAN- REDUCE.
THE DESIRE FOR CELL PHONES BY
DISABLING THEM. THANK GOD I GOT
IT SO THAT IN THE TIMELINE
AGAINST THIS POSES ON. THE ONE
LISTED IN THE REPORT WHERE IT'S-
ALL THE- OVER FROM NOW TOLD
TWENTY TWENTY SIX IS WHEN ALL
THE FACILITIES WOULD BE DONE.
YES THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY I DON'T
KNOW I APPRECIATE THE ANSWER BUT
STILL I THINK IT DOESN'T REALLY
MAKE SENSE TO ME HOW YOU COULD
BE SO SURE SO MANY YEARS OUT
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM BUT HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE NEXT
YEAR ABOUT YOUR OTHER PROGRAMS.
SO OKAY THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY OF WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
ENOUGH FOR ISSUE NUMBER THREE WE
HAVE. MULTIPLE PANELS- WITHIN-
WITHIN AND SO WE WILL GO WE WILL
HEAR FROM. FROM EACH PANEL AND
THEN WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS FOR
THE PANEL BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ONE SO JUST TO RECAP
PANEL ONE ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
GRANT PROGRAM. PANEL TO VERTICAL
PROSECUTION AND PENALTY COUNTER
DRUG TASK FORCE PROGRAM
EXPANSION SORRY POLITICS PANEL
FOR DOJ ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM AND DOJ TASK
FORCE PROGRAM SO WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE PANELISTS FOR EACH ONE
AND WE WILL ASK QUESTIONS AFTER
EACH PANEL. FOR EACH ONE ONE AT
THE SUB SUB ISSUES SO WE MAY
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST. THE FIRST
ONE ORGANIZED WITHOUT THE F.
GRANT PROGRAM. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KATIE HOWARD WITH THE PSPC IS
THE AUDIO OKAY. YES GREAT THANK
YOU I'M STARTING ON THE-
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM- AS IS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA THIS IS A
PROPOSAL FOR A COMPETITIVE
GRANT. UP WITH EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
THIS YEAR AND THEN THE NEXT TWO
BUDGET YEARS AS WELL SO TOTAL OF
THREE YEARS- THAT IS TO BE
AWARDED COMPETITIVELY TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES- TO
COMBAT ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME.
AND THIS WOULD INCLUDE WOULD
INCLUDE LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS
COUNTY SHERIFF'S AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS- MISTER JONES SAWYER
ON THIS COMMITTEE IS VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE SEC'S
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS
PROGRAMS- I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
BUT I JUST WANTED TO. ALSO
MENTION A COUPLE OF THOUGHT ON
THAT I'M AWARE HAVE HAVE COME
QUESTIONS THAT ACCOMPANY THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT. WHY IS THAT IT
MINISTRATION IS PRIORITIZING
THESE RESOURCES TO COMBAT
ORGANIZED RETAIL FACT- INSTEAD
FOCUS WAY WHEN THERE ARE A LOT
OF OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES
AND I THINK THE- PERSPECTIVE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION IS THAT THIS
IS A PROPOSAL. THAT ADDRESSES
THE SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
OF CONCERN CERTAINLY ARE TO THE
GOVERNOR OF THE ADMINISTRATION
BUT I THINK TOO MANY ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND THAT
THERE ARE OTHER IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES FOR STATE AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT. BUT OVER THE
LAST YEAR IN PARTICULAR AS
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT ISSUES
HAVE. CERTAINLY THAT SPOTLIGHT
IT APPEARS AN INTEREST IN
FINDING SOME COMPETITIVE GRANTS
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THAT'S
JUST A VERY QUICK OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSAL. CAITLIN O'NEILL AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
- WE ANALYZE THIS PROPOSAL AS A
PART OF A BROADER PUBLIC SEEK
SAFETY PACKAGE CONSISTING OF
NINE PROPOSALS ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS TOTALING A HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
DECLINING TO. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY
BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN. OF THE NINE PROPOSALS
FIVE HAVE THE GOAL OF THE BROAD
GOAL OF REDUCING ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT TWO OF ADDRESSING
FIREARMS AND TO DEAL WITH DRUG
TRAFFICKING OR OTHER CRIMES. WE
PROVIDE OUR DETAILED ASSESSMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A RECENT
PUBLICATION- AND WE HAVE HARD
COPIES HERE IT'S ALSO AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE. I'M GOING TO
GIVE SOME A BRIEF SUMMARY
SUMMARY OF OUR OVER ARCHING
COMMENTS ON THE PACKAGE AND THEN
DISCUSSED SOME CONCERNS ON THIS
PARTICULAR- PROPOSAL MY
COLLEAGUE MISLI WILL ALSO BE
PROVIDING COMMENTS ON. LATER
COMPONENTS OF THE PACKAGE ARE
PACKED COMPONENTS OF THE PACKAGE
THAT COME UP IN LATER- PANELS.
I'M SO MOVING ON TO MY OVER
ARCHING COMMENTS WE RAISE NO
CONCERNS WITH TO THE PROPOSALS
TOTALING SEVEN MILLION- ONE OF
WHAT WHICH IS COMING UP IN A
LATER PANEL. TODAY REGARDING THE
REMAINING FUNDING.
IT TO MEET THOSE GOALS AND THEN
ALIGN THE RESOURCES ACCORDINGLY
TO ENSURE THAT THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES ARE MET. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL PLAN WHICH AS
I MENTIONED GENERALLY TARGETS
THESE. BROAD GOALS OF REDUCING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT-
ADDRESSING FIREARMS AND REDUCING
DRUG TRAFFICKING AND OTHER
CRIMES. LACKS CLEAR AND SPECIFIC
OBJECTIVES FOR ACHIEVING EACH OF
THOSE SCHOOLS WHICH MAKES IT-
QUITE DIFFICULT TO ASSESS
WHETHER THE PROPOSALS WOULD BE
EFFECTIVE- FOR EXAMPLE THE TYPES
OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES THAT CAN
FALL UNDER ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT CAN BE QUITE BROAD. CAN
RANGE FROM TWO PEOPLE WORKING
TOGETHER TO STEAL MERCHANDISE TO
RETURN IT FOR STORE CREDIT. ON
TO A CRIMINAL ORGANIZATION THAT
IS EXPLOITING PEOPLE POTENTIALLY
AND STEALING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF MERCHANDISE AND SELLING
IT ONLINE. SO WITHOUT A CLEAR-
OBJECTIVE ADDS IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ASSESS WHICH TYPE OR- WHAT
ASPECT OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
THE GOVERNOR'S INTENDING TO
TARGET- WHICH IN TURN MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO IT- SS WORD WHETHER
THE PROPOSED STRATEGIES WOULD-
OR OR WHAT OTHER ACTIONS WOULD
MAKE SENSE TO EFFECTIVELY
TARGETED. AT TARGET THE
OBJECTIVES- WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES. TO ASSIST THE
LEGISLATURE IN DEVELOPING ITS
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES- OUR
PUBLICATION PREVENTS PRESENTS
DATA ON CRIME AND FIREARM TRENDS
. WE ARE TO DISCUSS FIREARM
TRENDS AS WELL AS SOME OPTIONS
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION AT
OUR FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
HEARING- AND SO NOW I'M GOING TO
DISCUSS VERY BRIEFLY SOME CRIME
TRENDS TO THE M. FOR- THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AT THAT
THINKS ABOUT ITS PUBLIC SAFETY
GOALS- AND BROADLY CRIME DATA WE
FOUND SUGGEST THAT THE GOVERNOR
SPECIFIC GOALS MAY NOT BE VERY
WELL TARGETED. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WHILE THERE'S NO
OFFICIAL DATA ON ALL RETAIL
THEFT- SHOPLIFTING DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY BETWEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY-
PRELIMINARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DATA FROM FOUR LARGE CITIES DOES
SUGGEST THAT OVERALL LARCENY.
WHICH INCLUDE SHOPLIFTING IS
INCREASING BUT IT HASN'T YET
RETURNED TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS
. I'M AT LEAST AS OF OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO WE FOUND
AND THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
INSTEAD WANT TO FOCUS ON
ADDRESSING RECENT CONCERNING
INCREASES IN HOMICIDES
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS AND MOTOR
VEHICLE RELATED THEFT. I WOULD
JUST NOTE HOWEVER THAT- SOME
EXPERTS AND RETAILERS HAVE NOTED
THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE AN
INCREASE IN BRAZEN F. AND-
OVERALL SOPHISTICATION OF
SHOPLIFTERS- THIS IS LARGELY
ANECDOTAL THERE REALLY ISN'T ANY
GOOD- STATEWIDE DATA ON THAT
ALTHOUGH NONETHELESS COULD. BE
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT- AND
I'D ALSO NOTE THAT- WHILE CRIMES
THEM STATEWIDE MAY NOT BE
SHOWING- AS A CONCERNING TREND
ON RETAIL THEFT- THERE COULD BE-REASON TO LOOK AT- LOCAL AREAS
OF CONCERN AS THAT IS THE CASE
THAT CRIME TRENDS OFTEN VERY
QUITE A BIT BY. REGION AND TYPE
OF CRIME. AND THEN FINALLY TO
THE EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN ADDRESSING CRIME
RELATED GOALS OUR PUBLICATION
PROVIDE SOME OPTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHICH
BROADLY- ARE IN THE CATEGORIES
ESSENTIALLY OF EXPANDING ON
EXISTING PROGRAMS OR PILOTING
RESEARCH BASED SOLUTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE EXAMPLE TO THE EXTENT
THE LEGISLATURE WANTED TO TARGET
THAT ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT-
THEIR RESEARCH BASED TOOLS AND
BEST PRACTICES THAT COULD BE
SCALED UP LIKE. USE OF
STRATEGICALLY PLACED CAMERAS OR
THEN FINALLY- GIVEN THAT THE
OVERALL CRIME RATE IS RELATIVELY
LOW I'M PARTICULARLY BY
HISTORICAL STANDARDS IT COULD BE
REASONABLE TO PRIORITIZE OTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY GOALS THAT ARE
NOT. DIRECTLY RELATED TO CRIME
REDUCTION. AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
OVER ARCHING COMMENTS AND- VERY
QUICKLY I WILL I WILL JUST
MENTION OUR CONCERNS- ON THIS.
PARTICULAR GRANT PROGRAM IN
PANEL ONE WHICH ALSO APPLIES TO
THE GRANT PROGRAM AND PANEL TO
BOTH OF WHICH ARE ADDRESSING
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT. AND SPECIFICALLY
WERE CONCERNED THAT THE- GRANT
PROGRAM AS PROPOSED WOULD
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
IMPLEMENTATION AUTHORITY TO BE A
SIXTY AFTER THE BUDGET IS
ENACTED WHICH WOULD MAKE IT.
VERY DIFFICULT TO ASSESS AT
LEAST AT THIS POINT HOW THE
MONEY WOULD ULTIMATELY BE
ALLOCATED AND USED AND IN TURN-
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER ULTIMATELY
THE FUNDING WOULD BE USED
EFFECTIVELY. IT ALSO MAKES IT
HARD TO RULE OUT THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE GRANTS WOULD SUPPLANT
LOCAL. FUNDING FOR EXAMPLE IS
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE FUNDING
WOULD GO TOWARD. INCREASING LAW
ENFORCEMENT PATROL OF RETAIL
LOCATIONS. OR BE USED FOR
EXAMPLE TO PURCHASE- CAMERAS OR
OTHER TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD.
ACHIEVE DIFFERENT OUTCOMES- AND
POTENTIALLY BE A MORE EFFECTIVE
USE OF LIMITED TERM FUNDING.
THIS IS THIS CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS AND I AM AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. I JUST NEWMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE THAT THE
GOAL OF THIS PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY WITH PANEL ONE IS
TO KIND OF EMPHASIZE AND
ENCOMPASS THE WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH AND PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR LOCALS TO COMBAT
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT- WE THINK
IT'S PART OF A LARGE. LOCAL AND
STATE KIND OF PACKAGE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE- HOLISTICALLY AND MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
PROPOSAL- YES. THANK YOU WE'VE.
AREAS A SEEMS TO BE THAT THEY'RE
PURCHASING AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE
A C. H. B. TAX TOUGH. C. H. B.
TASK FORCE. INCLUDING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN SACRAMENTO DO
WE KNOW IF THESE ARE AREAS WHERE
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT- OR JUST HOW HOW
DID WE MAKE. HOW DID WE GET TO
THAT POSITION CAN WE START THERE
. SURE JUST A MOMENT TO FINANCE
AGAIN I THINK. WE DECIDED TO
EXPAND THE H. P. DID THOSE.
SPECIFIC LOCATION BECAUSE WE HAD
SEEN.
DR IN THOSE AREAS ARE THOSE THE
ONLY AREAS WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A
CHP TASK FORCE. I CAN'T WAIT
THIS SPECIFIC AREA THAT SEEKS
PETER OR DOESN'T COVER SO I'M I
DIFFER TO THEM ON. WHAT PARTS OF
THIS BEST- SO I IT WHICH IS. I
THINK WE MIGHT THINK I'LL AND
THEN OF COURSE THAT WE ALL SHE-
DID HE SAID TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- BEING RESPONSE TO THEIR
DEFINITELY BEEN AND- IN THE NEWS
PER WE WANT TO MAKE SURE TO THE
IN THE SMALL. WAY THAT ARE DAHLE
TAX IN AB. IN A WAY THAT READ
THIS- THOSE HEADLINE AND THAT
RETAIL THEFT OUT THERE AND SO.
AND SO MY QUESTION IS THAT OUR
LINE OF QUESTIONS ARE COMING
FROM FROM THAT PLACE AND WE
START THERE AND SO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN SACRAMENTO MIGHT BE.
GOOD PLACES TO START IS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT MAYBE YOU. WE'RE
NOT FORGETTING OTHER PLACES I
MIGHT NEED THIS AS WELL- AND SO
THAT'S THAT THAT'S WHERE THAT'S
WITHOUT QUESTION IS COMING FROM
- AND THAT WE'RE NOT JUST PRIOR
TO A THEME BASED. ON ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE LIMITED
GROUP THE STAKEHOLDERS OUT THERE
AND SO THAT'S MY FIRST CONCERN
THERE MY SECOND CONCERN IS THAT
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT WE HAVE ANY
SORT OF METRICS TO ENSURE THAT
THE DOLLARS ARE ACTUALLY BEING
USED IN THE WAYS IN THE WAY THAT
WE INTENDED. AND SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OPEN TO
FINDING SOME SORT OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
THAT THE SELLERS ARE BEING USED
APPROPRIATELY. I JUST NEWMAN
PART IN A FINANCE WERE MORE THAN
HAPPY THE ADMINISTRATION IS AND
PART OF STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS TO WORK THROUGH THE
EXECUTIVE STEERING PROCESS AS WE
DEVELOP THE GRANTS AND KIND OF
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS TO ENSURE
THAT. THE MONEY IS BETTER SPENT
ARE ACCURATELY TRACKING IN KIND
OF REPORTED BY THE LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT BY FOREIGN IN OUR
ULTIMATELY AWARDED THESE GRANTS.
SO I SO LET ME BE CLEAR AT WHAT
MY NEXT QUESTION AND EVEN THIS
ONE THAT WE'RE HOPING TO GET
THIS INFORMATION BEFORE WE
APPROPRIATE THE SELLERS AND THAT
AFTER. THE MATTER- IT THINK EVER
GOING TO HONOR OUR DUTY WE NEED
THAT INFORMATION AHEAD OF TIME
AND SO WITH THAT MY QUESTION IS.
WHEN WILL BE WHEN WILL WE BE
RECEIVING ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW. THESE GRANTS WILL
OCCUR WITH THE FACT THAT THE
GRANTS THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
CAN APPLY FOR WHAT THE
PERMISSIBLE USE OF THE FUNDING.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA MEASURE THE
IMPACT OF THE FUNDING WHEN WILL
WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE. IF I MAY A JOB AND
THIS IS KATIE HOW WITH THE-
OFTEN AS THE LARGEST. CAN NEW
GRANT PROGRAMS AND THAT THE BCC
IS ASKED TO ADMINISTER. THEIR IN
THE PAST BEEN- SOME. PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE OR BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT REALLY SPELLS OUT WITH SOME
SPECIFICITY. SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE GOALS AND SO WE
WOULD BE OF COURSE ABSOLUTELY-
INTERESTED AND OPEN TO. WORKING
WITH YOU ON SOME OF THOSE
CRITERIA. THAT YOU MIGHT LIKE TO
ADD IN WE HEARD YOU ASKED TODAY
ABOUT. WHAT INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE ABOUT RATES OF
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT ACROSS
THE STATE AND WE CAN CERTAINLY
TRY TO PUT SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION TOGETHER. BUT- IN
GENERAL ARE THINGS LIKE- TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES OR PROGRAMS OR
EVEN TECHNOLOGY IT'S A TRUCK.
THAT MIGHT BE A HIGHER PRIORITY
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE THOSE KINDS OF
ADDITIONAL- DETAILED RULES COULD
CERTAINLY BE FELT TEN AS PART OF
BUDGET PROCESS. FOR THE GRANT
SPOKE OUT. AND THEN I THINK THAT
THE WAY THAT I WOULD LEAST LIKE
TO AT LEAST OFFER SOME-
INSURANCE PERHAPS IS THAT SINCE
THIS IS A COMPETITIVE GRANT-
ANY. LOOKED SECTION THAT WANTS
TO APPLY FOR THE FUNDING NEEDS
TO PROVIDE A PERSUASIVE
STATEMENT OF NEED. AND THAT
WOULD BE ONE OF THE RATING
CRITERIA- ON WHICH THEIR SUPPORT
. THE COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS
THAT GOAL CERTAINLY AND THE
STRUCTURE OF OUR- DC GRANTED.
PROCESS IS TO SAY LET'S HAVE A
LOOK. ON PROPOSALS B. AS- BASED
ON THE NEED THAT THAT COMES IN
ON THE PROPOSAL'S. IT'S THOSE
TWO DISTINCT THINGS CERTAINLY
ADDITIONAL. LANGUAGE CAN BE
ADDED HERE IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND- WE WOULD HAVE. HAD IT.
PROCESS THAT. THAT WOULD SERVE
TO- FUNDED PROGRAMS WERE THE
HIGHEST NEEDS ARE IDENTIFIED.
AND THEN FINALLY ON THE
PLANTATION WHICH WAS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE L. A. ARE
RAISED. WE ALWAYS SPECIFIED IN
GRANT AGREEMENT THAT THE FUNDING
HAS TO BE FOR NEW ACTIVITIES.
AND CAN'T SUPPLY. SO I WANT TO.
JUST MENTION THAT AS. WELL
THANKS. DO WE A MATRIX OF. A
PERSUASIVE. APPLICATION MY-
HELPED HER STICTION SALES WORRY
ABOUT EQUITY- ONE- SEPARATE FOR
THAT MAKING SURE THAT. IT WASN'T
JUST PERSUASIVE AND PAPER BUT
THAT IT WAS EFFECTIVE IN
PRACTICE. AS WELL AS WELL AS WE
CONTINUE TO THIS PROCESS THOSE
DETAILS ARE GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US. AND THIS.
BHOSLE COMPLETELY FAIR QUESTION-
WE CAN BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH EXAMPLES FROM OTHER GRANTS
BUT I THINK THE CONTENT OF THIS
ONE IS DISTINCT SO- YOU KNOW.
WHATEVER THE PRIORITY CERTAINLY
EQUITY IS IMPORTANT AS WELL-
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ONCE
DEVELOP THEN WE WOULD THEN HAVE
THE GRANTS DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
FLOW DIRECTLY FROM WHATEVER THE
LEGISLATURE- AND THE BUDGET
PROCESS HAS DICTATED I HOPE THAT
MAKES SENSE. SO LET'S JUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND WILL
WORK WITH US TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE HERE- METRICS- TO ENSURE
THE FUNDING IS BEING USED
PROPERLY AND CLEAR METRICS FOR
HOW YOU QUALIFY FOR OUR GRAND
THE SISAL STRANDS BEFORE. WE
ADOPT THIS BUDGET. YOU CERTAINLY
CAN'T- TYPICALLY THINGS LIKE THE
SIZE OF INDIVIDUAL GRANTS IS-
LEFT FOR A COMMITTEE OF A
VARIETY OF SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS- TO DETERMINE TO WORK
THROUGH AND DETERMINE BUT IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO SAY YOU
KNOW THAT TO SET SOME LIMITS ON
THAT THAT IS ABSOLUTELY WITHIN
YOUR- YOU KNOW. ABILITY TO DO.
SO TO BE CLEAR THOUGHT ABOUT
SETTING LIMITS OF SO FORTH WHICH
IS WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
DOLLARS ARE YOU SEEN BEING USED
EFFECTIVELY- AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE CONFIDENT IN TELLING THE
TAXPAYERS. HOW ARE YOU SEEING
THEIR TAX DOLLARS TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES I HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS BUT ACTUALLY WANT TO
GIVE MY COLLEAGUES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A AS THE DIGITAL
QUESTIONS MISTER LUCKY. YEAH
THANK YOU I'D FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
OF KNOWLEDGE IN. THIS HUGE
PROBLEM- THIS IS A VERY VERY BIG
PROBLEM. AND AS A MATTER OF FACT
I BELIEVE THAT PART OF OUR-
FRUSTRATION. IS AS- WAS
ANNOUNCED EARLIER THAT. THE THE
NUMBERS ARE INDICATING THAT-
THIS IS NOT AS BIG A PROBLEM AS
IT REALLY IS AND I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE WE HAVE. LACK OF REAL
DATA. ON SHOWING HOW WIDESPREAD
AND HOW DEEP. THIS PROBLEM HAS
BECOME- I KNOWS TO PUBLIC SAFETY
A REALITY THAT- MY DAUGHTER WHO
RECENTLY WAS EMPLOYED BY
RETAILER. WAS INSTRUCTED BY HER
SUPERVISION. THAT WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY OBSERVE SOMEBODY.
STEALING A GARMENT THAT THEY
WERE NOT EVEN TO BRING ATTENTION
TO IT. MUCH LESS REPORTED. SO I
COULD TELL YOU THAT'S THE
REALITY THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW. AND IT'S BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID- THEY DON'T
WANT VIOLENCE THEY DON'T WANT
ALL THE NEGATIVE- CONSEQUENCES
OF REPORTING AND SO WHAT I'M
HOPING IS THAT- BY THIS
PROGRAMMING. BRINGING ATTENTION
TO THIS PROBLEM THAT MAYBE SOME
OF THE RETAILERS WILL BE MORE
ENGAGED TO COOPERATE. AND TO
GIVE US SOME REAL DATA SO THAT
WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE SEVERITY
OF THIS PROBLEM. AND WE CAN A
DESK ADDRESS IT IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY. AND YOU KNOW TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
HOT OF MONEY. SO I'M HOPING THAT
WE WILL DIRECTED IN A WAY THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY COLLECT- GOOD
INFORMATION. AND WE CAN TRACK
OUTCOMES THAT CAN HELP US. OF
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM IN SOME
KIND OF MEANINGFUL WAY AND NOT
JUST SUPERFICIALLY- I'M VERY
VERY EXCITED FOR. THE BEGINNING
OF SOMETHING. THAT REALLY NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED- BECAUSE WE'RE
ALL IMPACTED BY IT ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER AND SO. I'M THANKFUL FOR
THE GOVERNOR RECOGNIZING THIS
AND IT MAY NOT BE EXACTLY THE-
OF AS MEANINGFUL AS- WE COULD
MAKE IT BUT- IT'S A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION SO I'M VERY
THANKFUL FOR IT. AND I JUST HOPE
THAT WE WILL BE SMART AND THE
WAY THAT WE IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM AND THAT WE WILL ADDRESS
IT IN A WAY THAT ACTUALLY HAS
MEANING. AND WHAT KIND OF
SERVICE A DETRIMENT TO THOSE WHO
ARE CHOOSING TO- EXPLOIT OTHER
PEOPLE- ESPECIALLY RETAILERS
THAT IT'S BECOME VERY VERY
HURTFUL AND I'M VERY EXCITED FOR
SOME GOOD OUTCOMES. THANK YOU MR
LACKEY AND- NOT PURSUE THIS WITH
THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL TO ME.
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT BILL AND THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO. THEN WHEN IT
SUNSET IT GOT IT RE. PATTERSON
SAID EXTENDED- I WAS OVER-
OVERJOYED WHEN THE GOVERNOR CAME
OUT WITH ADDITIONAL MONEY NOT
ONLY FOR THIS PROGRAM BUT THEY
ALSO SAY THAT IN ITS PRESENT
FORM IT WAS WORKING UNDER CHP
AND I DON'T THINK THE CHP GETS
ENOUGH CREDIT FOR THE INCREDIBLE
JOB THAT THEY'VE DONE IN IN IN
IN THE SUCCESSES THAT THEY HAVE
BOTH BEEN. PROSECUTING PEOPLE
WITH FELONIES AND DEALING WITH
PEOPLE ON THE MISDEMEANOR LEVEL
AND GETTING THEM TO PROGRAMS-
AGAIN IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE SOMEONE WROTE
ORGANIZATIONS DO AN EXCEPTIONAL
JOB. AND WE JUST KIND OF IGNORED
IT AND SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE COMMEND THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL FOR THE FOR THEIR
ROLE. IN GETTING THIS DONE- A
BUDGET THAT THE VOTING THE REAL
PROBLEM IS- THE CONFLICTING
INFORMATION WHETHER OR NOT IT
WHETHER IT'S HIGHER OR LOWER-
THE REAL PROBLEM IS FEAR. IT
COULD BE WE COULD BE AT ZERO.
AND PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT CRIME IS
UP AND FEARFUL. THIS EMOTIONAL.
YOU KNOW PERCEPTION IS REALITY
AND IF THEY BELIEVE THAT- CRIME
IS UP AND THE FEAR OF CRIME THEN
THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN. WE CAN
DO ABOUT IT STATISTICALLY RITUAL
THE MODEST OF TEXAS YOU WANT BUT
IF THEY ARE AFRAID. TO COME
OTHER HOMES BECAUSE THEY SEE
HOMELESS PEOPLE WALKING AROUND
OR A LOOK ON THE TV NAY C. SMASH
AND GRABS- THAT IS THAT IT AND
IT'S REAL. LET'S LET'S FACE IT
THAT IS A REAL REAL FEAR AND I
THINK THAT'S THE DAILY TIMES
POLL SHOWS THAT. PEOPLE REALLY
DO FEEL IT. AT THE- AGREEMENTS
LACKEY THE GOVERNOR WE NEED TO
BE THANKING THE GOVERNOR'S I
THINK HE HE UNDERSTANDS THAT
THIS DATA CALIFORNIA AND ALL OF
US NEED TO DO SOMETHING AND THIS
IS AFTER. TO GET THE LEGISLATURE
INVOLVED TO GET THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE INVOLVED AND- COMMITTEE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE-
ACTIVIST GROUPS INVOLVED TO GO
AT THIS ORGANIZED RETAIL. THEFT
OF BRAIN. ALL THE- AND I'M GONNA
REMEMBER WHAT MISS HOWARD TOLD
US AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
BORDER STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. THE LEGISLATURE
DOES HAVE TO GIVE THEM SOME KIND
OF GUARD RAILS AND DIRECTION. IF
FEDERAL CRIMINAL MISCHIEF IT IS
MR LACKEY REMEMBERS ANY OTHER
BOARD MEMBERS REMEMBER- WE HAD
ASKED B. S. YOU SEE ABOUT
ANOTHER PROGRAM THEY WERE GIVING
OUT GRANTS FOR. AN KENNEDY
ANSWER CAME BACK THE
LEGISLATURE. TOLD HIM JUST TO DO
THE REPORT TO PUT HIM UP ON A
SHELF. WHICH IS WHAT THEY DID.
WHICH IS WHAT WE TELL THEM TO DO
WE DID NOT ASK FOR THE
ACCOUNTABILITY METRONET AFTER TO
SYNTHESIZE IT AND COME BACK WITH
DATA TO THIS GROUP. ABOUT HOW
EFFECTIVE THAT PARTICULAR GRANT
PROGRAM WAS AND SO SHE'S
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IF WE'RE GOING
TO GET THIS RIGHT WE HAVE TO
JOIN WITH THE GOVERNOR TO PUT
DOWN WHAT WE WANT TO SEE. A LOT
OF THIS HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT ARE GOING
TOWARD ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT.
NOT ONLY IS THE GOALS BUT JUST
CLEAR RESOURCES OF WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE AND WHAT IS THE HIGHEST
PRIORITIES ON DOWN- AND OF
COURSE IMPLEMENTATION.
IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF. THE REASON
WHY I BELIEVE THE GOVERNOR HAD
HERE TO CITIES WITHWITH CHP
BECAUSE CHP IS TAKING THE LEAD
ON THIS. THESE GRANTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO GO TO A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO KIND OF DO THE
SAME THING IN CONJUNCTION WITH
C. H. P. OR DO IT ON THEIR OWN
WE HAVE AN TO FIND AT THE SO
WE'RE PUTTING THAT ON B. SEC.
THE CANADA FIND IT WE PROBABLY
NEED TO HELP THEM TO FIND IT TOO
BECAUSE NOT EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY BELIEVES IN
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT- THEY
BELIEVE FELONIES LOCKING UP
PEOPLE. THROWING AWAY THE KEY
AND THAT'S IT NASTA THAT'S HOW
YOU SOLVE IT I THINK IS A MULTI.
APPROACH AND THAT'S WHAT THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT BUILDERS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS MONEY IS
SUPPOSED TO DO BUT- AT THE END
OF THE DAY- WE DO HAVE TO
PROVIDE MORE. MEAT TO IT AND-
AND HOPEFULLY MISS HOWARD CAN
COMMENT ON WHAT ELSE SHE NEEDS
SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THAT FOR
YOU SO THAT AFTER YEAR IT GOES
BY IF WE ASK FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES WHAT WHAT IS BEEN DONE.
SO THAT. MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
OTHER SIDE. WE'RE NOT HAVING
THIS DEBATE FOR EXAMPLE ON. IS
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT CRIMES
GOING UP GOING DOWN THE IN
BETWEEN A LEVELED OUT THAT WE-
THAT MAYBE THAT'S PART OF WHAT
WE REQUIRE- LAW ENFORCEMENT IT
GET THESE GRANTS THAT THEY ASK
IS HOW THEY TELL US HOW
EFFECTIVE IT'S BEEN. BUT MORE
IMPORTANT WHAT DID THEY USE TO
GET IT DONE HOPEFULLY COMPORTS
WITH THE ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
BILL. AND IN AND COME UP WITH
MAYBE SOME INGENIOUS WAYS TO GET
THIS DONE. LIKE TECHNOLOGY. I
WANT TO GET AWAY WITH SOME OF
THE THINGS I'VE HEARD ON
TECHNOLOGY IN ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT BUT SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE THINGS ARE. KIND OF. IN THE
FUTURE SPACE AGE PROBABLY WAY
ABOVE MY TECHNOLOGY LEVEL THAT
THEY CAN USE TO GO BACK AND
TRACED BACK TO STOLEN MATERIAL
BACK TO THE PEOPLE WHO WHO'VE
TAKEN IT THAT COULD BE PART OF
THE GRANT. THE DALLAS MAY BE
PART OF GIVING MORE MONEY TO
RETAILERS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
TECHNOLOGY- WORKING WITH
RETAILERS DO DUE TO TECHNOLOGY
SO THAT THEY CAN DO THAT. LET'S
BE SMART. ABOUT THE GRANT
PROGRAM. AND MAKE IT MORE ROBUST
AND- ULTIMATELY MAKE SURE
THEY'RE SOMEBODY IN CHARGE. AND
THAT THAT WHOEVER'S IN CHARGE OF
CHP OR WHETHER IT'S A OTHERS
USED TO WORK MORE FOR THINKING
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY I WANT TO
USE ALL THESE TECHNIQUES AND
WANTED TO EVERYTHING THAT THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT BILL
DOES. THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
COBBLE TOGETHER SOMETHING THAT
IS OUT OF THE BOX MICHAEL TO
WITH THEIR NORMALLY DO BUT THEY
DO SOMETHING THAT- INVENTIVE IN
NEW AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS
MONEY IS REALLY. REALLY FOR AND
SO I WILL ASK MISS HOWARD AND
SHE CAN SHE CAN COMMENT ON
WHETHER OR NOT- WHAT KIND OF
GUARDRAILS WE SHOULD PUT ON HERE
ARE NO GUARD RAILS OR WHAT WE
NEED TO DO. TO MAKE. FOR ME THE
MOST IMPORTANT PART OF THIS IS
THE GRANT PROGRAM. TO THE GRANT
PROGRAM ULTIMATELY STARTS BY N.
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. ONCE YOU
START TO GET BUY IN FROM BOTH.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY ARE ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT I THINK WE'LL GET WE'LL
GET A LONG WAY TOWARD REDUCING.
OR AT LEAST IDENTIFY WHAT IT IS
AND THEN REDUCING THAT AND SO
THAT- EVERYONE FEELS SAFE.
BECAUSE AGAIN OUR OUR REPEAT
THIS AGAIN THE FEAR. IS
ABSOLUTELY- RIO AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN COME UP WITH SOME BEST
PRACTICES. ON HOW WE DEAL WITH
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- THE VERTICAL
PROSECUTION. AND ALSO HOPEFULLY
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT. ACROSS
COUNTY LINES WHEN PEOPLE STEAL
SOMETHING I BELIEVE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE DOJ. BEING
ABLE TO HANDLE THAT WELL LET'S
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
AND RESOURCES IF SOMEBODY STILL
SOMETHING VENTURA COUNTY. AND IN
L. A. COUNTY SOMEBODY'S IN
CHARGE TO BE ABLE TO PROSECUTE
ACROSS THOSE COUNTY LINE.
BECAUSE THAT'S JUST AS IMPORTANT
AS IS ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE CAN
AGGREGATED UP SO THAT IF THE
PERSON NEEDS TO BE CHARGED WITH
A FELONY DAY OUR INTERNET
SKIRTING AROUND LAW. FROM COUNTY
TO COUNTY TO COUNTY AND I
BELIEVE SOME OF THIS IS IN HERE-
TO IT TO ADDRESS THAT- WITH THE
JORDAN DOJ ORGANIZED RETAIL
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM. AND THE DOJ
TASK FORCE- SO. THERE'S A LOT
THERE'S A LOT. I MEAN A LOT IN
HERE. THAT IT MAY ONLY BE THE
START. BUT I THINK IT'S A NOT A
GOOD START I THINK IS A GREAT
START FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
COLLEAGUES FROM THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE THIS IS A GOOD GOOD
START. THAT WE'RE TRYING RIGHT
HERE. SO IF YOU AN ANSWER ABOUT
WHAT YOU NEED BE SEC. SO THE
WEEKEND IS DONE RIGHT. THE FIRST
TIME. M. WE'RE NOT YELLING AT
YOU IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T GET IT RIGHT
. YOU HAVEN'T YELLED AT ME YES.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER OF THE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS THAT I'VE
HEARD YOUR NAME FROM THAT
COMMITTEE SEEM TO FALL INTO.
THREE GENERAL TOPICS- PRIORITIES
NEEDS PRIORITIES FOR THE FUNDING
HOW THERE'S A GLITCH
DEMONSTRATION AND NEED IN THE
GRANT PROPOSALS AND THE DESIRED
REPORTING ON OUTCOMES- SO I'M
NOT READY TO ANSWER ANY DETAILS
THAT ARE OFFERING A DETAILED
PROPOSAL IN THOSE THREE AREAS
BUT MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
STAFF ON. YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
THAT MIGHT INCLUDE AND LIKE I
SAID IN OTHER GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE COME THROUGH THE STATE
BUDGET PROCESS THEIR PET. YOU
KNOW YOU'RE GONNA PROTEST HE CAN
IN TERMS OF THE LEVEL OF
DIRECTION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
GETS THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT. AND I BEEN OUT A GET OFF
MY SOAPBOX NOW LAST YEAR I
WOULD. RECOMMEND THAT YOU IT
WITH THIS COMMITTEE YOU CAN TALK
TO BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE I
THINK WE HAVE. MEMBERS HERE THAT
COULD GIVE YOU SOME VALUABLE
INFORMATION ON HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD. WITH THIS. THANKS.
PANEL TWO VERTICAL PROSECUTION
OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT AGAIN
THAT'S A K. IS THAT CORRECT TO
BE A CC THEN MISSILE NEO AND AN
APARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER THIS- HOPE PROPOSAL HAS
TO DO WITH- PROVIDING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY- THROUGH TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE FOUR- THE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR DISTRICT ATTORNEYS I
TO CREATE DEDICATED RETAIL THEFT
PROSECUTION TEAMS I'M SURE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
QUITE FAMILIAR WITH VERTICAL
PROSECUTION AND THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING BURKE PROSECUTION TEAMS.
AS MR JONES SAWYER HAS PROVIDED
A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES MR LACKEY
AS WELL- ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
. REALLY COMPLICATED- ENDEAVOR
AND- THERE CAN BE. DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS YOU KNOW MANY
DIFFERENT CITIES AND COUNTIES
INVOLVED LARGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN COORDINATED EFFORTS
TO- CONNECT ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT CRIMES IN A VERTICAL
PROSECUTION STRUCTURE IS REALLY
HELPFUL BECAUSE THEY THEN YOU
HAVE DEDICATED ATTORNEYS THAT
CAN BE. FAMILIAR WITH THE CASE
OF THE INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN
THE CASES THE CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL TASK FORCES AND
THE- ELEMENTS THAT ARE THRIVING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT SO WE
THINK THAT- THE VIEW OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT- ARTICLE
PROSECUTION ON THESE KINDS OF
CRIMES IS A SOUND INVESTMENT- DO
YOU GET BETTER RESULTS SO- YOU
WANT TO ENSURE. THAT THE RAY ARE
THERE TO- TO GO AFTER- AND HOLD
RESPONSIBLE- THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN THESE SORTS OF
ACTIVITIES AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
YOUR QUESTIONS OF COURSE. GEN
MASANYA. THE COMMENTS THAT I
GAVE ON PANEL ONE APPLY TO THIS
ITEM AS WELL. DEFIED IN A MIN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAN SORRY JUST
TECH I GUESS REITERATE WHAT YOU
HAD MENTIONED EARLIER AS FAR AS
THAT. YOU KNOW COMPLEXITY THESE
TYPES OF CASES THAT AS MISS
HOWARD SAID WE REALLY WANT TO
FIND TO ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW
PROSECUTION HAPPENS THE INNING
IN ADDITION WITH ENFORCEMENT AND
IT THERE'S A LOT OF KIND OF
COORDINATION THAT GOES ON
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROSECUTOR OFFICES. AND THE
RETAILERS WHO ARE IMPACTED- AND
WE JUST REALLY THINK THAT
FUNDING IS NECESSARY TO KIND OF
COMPLETE THE WHOLE PICTURE.
JANKY THERE WILL BRING A BATCH
COMMITTEE VIBE MY ONLY QUESTION
IS JUST. JUST FROM AN
IMPLEMENTATION STANDPOINT ARE
YOU ARE YOU LOOKING AT THIS
MONEY TO GO IN. AND GET IN A
COORDINATOR TO COORDINATE WITH
THE DA LAW LAW ENFORCEMENT
JUDICIAL SO THAT THEY IN IN
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS- ARE IS
IT. HOW DO YOU CAN I MEAN YOU
NEED TO TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
PAY FOR WHAT THAT MIGHT BE THE
BEST WAY TO SAY IT. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE GETTING SOME
OF YOUR QUESTIONS FROM- DAILYO
AND OTHERS WHO HOW HOW IS. HOW
IS THIS IMPLEMENTED I GUESS IS
WHAT I'M SAYING. IT IS ANYBODY
NOW- WE HADN'T FIGURED OUT YET.
THE THIS IS KATIE HOWARD WITH
THE BSE THEME MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THIS FUNDING IS TO GO TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS OFFICES TO
SUPPORT VERTICAL PROSECUTION
TEAM- AND- IN TERMS OF WHETHER
THERE WOULD BE WITHIN THE TEN
MILLION IF SOME OF THAT FUNDING
WOULD GO TO OTHER ENTITIES ARE
JURISDICTIONS- I DON'T THINK
WE'VE GOTTEN INTO THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL IN THE CONVERSATION AS
YET BUT THE PROPOSAL IS TO FIND-
THE PARTICLE PROSECUTION WORK
WITHIN DA'S OFFICES. SO SELECCI
. YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU IS
THERE ANY GUESSTIMATE ON- THE
NUMBER OF PROSECUTIONS. THIS
WILL FUND OR WHAT YOU'RE
PREPARED TO PROSECUTE. WHEN THE
NUMBER OF CASES. MISTER LUCKY I
DON'T HAVE THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL
AT THIS MOMENT. OKAY SO YOU YOU
I KNOW DISCOVERED RECALL BACK
AND FORTH BUT DO SO YOU WOULDN'T
HAVE. IF THERE'S A BACKLOG THAT
THEY COULD I JUST CASES THEY
HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO AND IS IT IS
THERE A BACKLOG. AGAINST PART OF
WHAT MR MAY REFLECT HE'S GETTING
TO BALANCE THE NUMBER OF CASES
BUT- THAT THIS WILL GO TO BUT
ALSO. ARE NOT ABLE TO GET TO IT
MAY NEED IS ADDITIONAL MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO. DO TO REDUCE THE
BACKLOG OR GET TO THESE CASES.
AND IF I COULD JUST CLARIFY IT
SEEMS LIKE THIS IS SUPPOSED TO
COVER TWO YEAR PERIOD. AND SO.
I'M JUST WONDERING. ARE THEY HAD
THERE'S GOTTA BE SOME KIND OF AN
APPROXIMATION- SO WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE. THE FUNDS AVAILABLE TO-
CARRY OUT THOSE PROSECUTIONS
ESPECIALLY THROUGH VERTICAL
PROCESS. THE MOST RETARDED. MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROPOSAL IS
THAT IT'S NOT SO MUCH TO ADDRESS
A BACKLOG OF MR JONES SAWYER BUT
RATHER THAT IT'S TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY WITHIN DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES TO FORM
VERTICAL PROSECUTION TEAM SO TO
FIND- THE ATTORNEYS AND OTHER
STAFF WOULD BE WORKING ON
PROSECUTING ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT IN A WAY THAT IS SEEN TO
HAVE THE ADVANTAGES FOR THIS
KIND OF- CRYING SO. THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND YES IT'S OVER
A THREE YEAR PERIOD IN TERMS OF
THE- THE FUNDING PROPOSAL MISTER
LUCKY AND I THINK THE NOTION IS
WILL HAVE SOME INFORMATION OVER
THAT PERIOD OF TIME ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT THE RESULTS HAVE BEEN
HOW SUCCESSFUL IT'S BEEN IF THAT
TEN MILLION DOLLARS WAS A PRETTY
GOOD ESTIMATE AS TO STATEWIDE
NEED YOU KNOW SOMETIMES WHEN
PROPOSALS NEW GRANT PROPOSALS
COME OUT- YOU KNOW SEE THERE'S
A- GRANT PROGRAM FOR FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE MAY RECEIVE.
THREE OR FOUR TIMES THAT NUMBER-
YOU KNOW DOLLARS IN TERMS OF
THAT REQUESTED GRANT
APPLICATIONS SO UNTIL WE LAUNCH
IT WE CAN'T REALLY BE SURE MY
SENSE IS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT LIKE TEN MILLION WAS A
REASONABLE PLACE TO START
THERE'S NO GUESSWORK INVOLVED TO
BE SURE OF ONE FINAL QUESTION
FRACTURE BLACKIE HAVE WE START
ANY INPUT AT ALL FROM THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S WITHIN THE
STATE. GET THEIR. THEIR INPUT ON
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT. I AM
NOT SURE IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I HAVE BEEN FORMALLY
DONE THAT AT THIS POINT. DEAL
WITH MAY HAVE MORE INFORMATION
HI JUSTIN EDELMAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVEN'T BEEN ACTIVELY
YOU KNOW COLLABORATING WITH THE-
SPECIFIC DISTRICT ATTORNEYS FOR
THIS PROPOSAL IT'S LARGELY.
DRIVEN OFF OF CHP'S INFORMATION
ON THEIR KIND OF ARRESTS AND
WHAT THEIR YOU KNOW.
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE RESULTED IN
BUT AGAIN THE INTENTION WAS TO
SIT DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND KIND
OF BUILDING UP A COMPLEX. WORK
OF. WHO ARE MORE MORE SPECIFIC
WE FOCUSED ON ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
PROSECUTIONS CAN OCCUR LOCALLY.
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME LIKE IT
WOULD BE A LOGICAL SUGGESTION TO
INCLUDE THEM IN SOME. PART OF
THIS PROCESS. BUT THIS COULD BE
A WAY TO KICKSTART. APRIL
PROGRAM IN DIFFERENT DAYS
OFFICE- I THE CONCERN IT
PROBABLY IS JUST SO IF YOU'RE
LISTENING IS. I THINK IS MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY
IN THERE TO ACCOMPLISH WHATEVER
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF THIS IS
. IN AN HOUR BAR IT'S TOO MUCH
MONEY THAT IT COULD BE HANDLED
INTERNALLY WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES AND MONEY AND THEY
ONLY NEED FIVE MILLION WHICH
MEANS AND THE REST WILL GO BACK
TO GENERAL FUND BUT IT WAS. THE
QUESTION WAS MORE IF YOU NEED TO
TWENTY. I DON'T THINK WE WOULD
BE. UPSET IT GIVING YOU MORE
MONEY IF WE KNEW THIS WOULD
HELP. IN REDUCING ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT THAT'S- IF YOU GET
A SENSE OF WHERE THESE QUESTIONS
ARE COMING FROM. THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL. OKAY WITH THAT WOULD GO
TO A PANEL THREE. CONTRA DRUG
TASK FORCE PROGRAM EXPANSION- I
HAVE A MAJOR GENERAL MATTHEW
BEAVERS CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT THEN I NEED TO LEAVE
FROM LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND
THEN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES WE'VE GOT
YOU FOR EIGHT TO SAID JAY IT IS
A BIT THE GENERAL MATT BEAVERS
AND THE DEPUTY ADJUTANT GENERAL
OF CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT SUPPOSED TO BE WITH
YOU TODAY. SO THIS BUDGET ITEM
THAT PROVIDES FOR A ONE TIME A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION- TO OUR
EXISTING COUNTER NARCOTICS TASK
FORCE OUR EXISTING PROGRAM IS
FRANKLY WHILE THE OVERSUBSCRIBED
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL AND- THIS
DEPARTMENT TO FURTHER AUGMENT.
OUR A SUPPORT TO THE STATES FOR
I INTENSELY DRUG TRAFFICKING
AREAS AS WELL AS TO OUR FEDERAL
STATE LOCAL AND TRIBAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. IT'S
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT IN THAT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SEIZURES OF
HEROIN THREATEN ALL THE COCAINE
THAT WE SUPPORTED- INCREASED BY
FIVE HUNDRED AND 77% FOR HEROIN
TWO THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT. FOR FENNEL
AND 68% FOR COCAINE FURTHER THIS
DOCUMENTATION WILL INCREASE CAN
INCREASE OUR SUPPORT TO THE
RATIFICATION OF CARTEL FUNDED
INDUSTRIAL SCALE ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA CULTIVATION IT'S
ABSOLUTELY DESTROYING OUR
COLLEGE OF OUR STATE NEGLEY
IMPACTS OUR STATE SO LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. AND WITH
THAT'LL TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS. ANY
DAILY WITH THE LATEST AND
OFFICE- MY COLLEAGUE NATHANAEL
GAVE OUR COMMENTS ON THE BROADER
. I'M NOT GOING TO DO THEM
AGAIN. BUT FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY
ON THIS PROPOSAL FOR ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE REFERENCED WAS-
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S OVERALL PLAN
LACKED CLEAR OBJECTIVES FOR
ACHIEVING. THE INTENDED PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS AND ALONG THOSE
LINES WE FOUND THAT CERTAIN
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
PACKAGE INCLUDING THIS ONE.
MIGHT NOT BE STRUCTURED TO
ACHIEVE THE INTENDED OUTCOMES.
AND SO OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS TO REDUCE
OPIOID OVERDOSES AS WELL AS
CRIMES AND VIOLENCE RELATED TO
THE SMUGGLING AND DISTRIBUTION
OF ILLEGAL DRUGS. HOWEVER ON THE
FLIP SIDE- OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT REQUESTS FOR
ASSISTANCE TEND TO INVOLVE
TARGETING ILLEGAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATION AND TRAFFICKING.
WHICH IS A SEPARATE AND
REASONABLE ST MICHAEL BUT
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY ONE THAT
AND THE SAME. SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE STATE'S PRIORITY IS
REDUCING OVERALL OVERDOSE DEATHS
LINKED TO ILLEGAL DRUGS THIS
PROPOSAL AS IT'S CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED MIGHT NOT BE THE BEST
WAY OF ACHIEVING THAT. SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HM
WEBER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME BUT WILL
BE ON STANDBY FOR ANY QUESTIONS
LIKE I HELP WITH. OKAY. SO IT
WAS A JUST A CLARIFICATION SORRY
IT. THIS IS FOR DAILYO SO ARE
ARE YOU SAYING THEY ARE PUTTING
TOO MUCH IN ONE BASKET OR THAT
MAYBE SHOULD FOCUS IN ON WHICH
IS A BIG PROBLEM GROWS IN THE
STATE WHERE THE- THE MILITARY
MAY HAVE TO BAND WITH- TO. DO A
QUICK MINUTE OR WHATEVER IT IS
TO BE ABLE TO CAMPUS AN AREA
LARGE GALLON. GO AFTER GROWS AS
OPPOSED TO. MAYBE COMING INTO
NEIGHBORHOODS AND DEALING WITH
IT AND ALL I MEAN I'M NOT IT IS
AN IMPLEMENTATION. CHALLENGE IT
IT TIES BACK TO ON THE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOUR COMMENT
ABOUT OUTCOMES FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT
AND SO WHAT ARE THE INTENDED
OUTCOMES AND SO IN REVIEWING OUR
REVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PACKAGE. THE GOAL SEEMS TO BE
REDUCING OPIOID DEATHS LINKED TO
ILLEGAL DRUGS. ON THE FLIP SIDE
THAN WHAT WE'RE BALANCING OFF
IS- AS REFERENCE THE PROGRAM IS
OVER SUBSCRIBED SUBSCRIBED AND
THERE ARE LOTS OF REQUESTS FOR
ASSISTANCE. THE REQUEST THOUGH-
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THE VAST
MAJORITY RELATES TO ILLEGAL
CANNABIS CULTIVATION AND
TRAFFICKING AND SO THAT'S WHY
WE'RE SAYING THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE IN THINKING ABOUT
ITS PRIORITY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MONEY IS ALIGNED WITH
THE GOAL THE SPECIFIC GOAL AN
OUTCOME THAT'S DESIRED AND SO IF
THE GOAL. IS TO REDUCE. OPIOID
DEATHS OR REDUCE DRUG THAT'S
TIED TO ILLEGAL DRUGS YOU MIGHT
WANT TO RESTRUCTURE THIS
PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ACCOMPLISH THAT. OKAY SO IF WE
WANTED TO RESTRUCTURE IT TO JUST
DEAL WITH. ILLEGAL GROWS. AND SO
A WHOLE TWENTY MILLION. WITH
THAT MAKE. SOME KIND OF SENSE SO
THEY HAD A PROGRAM THAT COULD
WELL DELINEATED WHAT EACH STEP
THAT WOULD BE SO WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TARGETING
ILLEGAL CANNABIS CULTIVATION
TRAFFICKING IS A REASONABLE GOAL
IS JUST A DIFFERENT STATEWIDE
GOAL AND SO WHEN YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT ALL OF YOUR DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES PUBLIC SAFETY AND
EVEN WITHIN PUBLIC SAFETY IF
IT'S CRIMES SUCH AS AUTO THEFTS-
HOMICIDES OR FIRE ARMS LIKE THIS
COMMITTEE AS DESCRIBED
PREVIOUSLY- THIS COULD.
ADDRESSING CANNABIS COULD BE
ANOTHER PRIORITIES SO IT'S
REALLY JUST A LIST OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THINKING ABOUT
IT IS A LIST OF LIKE WHAT ARE
ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS WE WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH IN TERMS OF USING
THE MONEY TO ACHIEVE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. JERRY.
THAT WHAT IS IT YEAH I GET THAT
ITCH WHICH COMES FUND PURSE
CHICKEN I ATE BUT I THINK WE CN
A WE JUST PROBABLY NEED A LITTLE
MORE FLESHING OUT- BECAUSE I
THINK WE DON'T KNOW HOW ON THE
FENTANYL OR THE DRUG USE- I
DON'T THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SITTING TANKS IN SOUTH LA TO GO
DEAL WITH FEDERAL. SO HOW DOES
THE MILITARY. FIT IN THAT PART
AYE RIGHT- I THINK WE ALL WANNA
PERCENT CONCEDE A MILITARY
FLYING OVER. GROWS OR ARE GOING
AFTER THAT- I THINK WE CAN. FEEL
THAT BUT IT IT MAY JUST MEAN- I
WAS THE MAJOR GENERAL COMING
BACK AND EXPLAINING TO US HOW
THE OTHERS WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED
AND HOW THIS MONEY WOULD BE
USED- SO WE HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING. OF WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO AND- WE OPTED TO GO
THROUGH THAT RIGHT NOW. AS THE
HOURS. GETTING PRETTY LATE. SO
I'D LIKE TO MOVE ON TO THE PANEL
NUMBER FOUR- DOJ ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME ENTERPRISE- O. R.
C. E. PROGRAM IN DOJ TASK FORCE
PROGRAM. BOB ASHLEY HART FROM
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
NEED TO LEAD THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND GET
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
ASHLEE HEART BUDGET OFFICE DIRK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE- THERE TO DO JEFF
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THIS
PARTICULAR PANEL OF THE AGENDA
ITEM AT THE GOVERNOR'S PURPOSE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
IN THE FIRST PROPOSAL. AS PART
OF A MULTI AGENCY PROPOSAL SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THREE
YEARS AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ONGOING FOR THE DOJ TO SUPPORT
REGIONAL TASK FORCES COMBATING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT AND
PROSECUTE RETAIL THEFT CASES
THAT SPAN MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS. THIS REQUEST WILL
ALLOW DOJ'S DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO EXPAND ITS WHITE
COLOR INVESTIGATIVE TEAM PROGRAM
WHICH WILL TARGET COMPLEX
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISES. AND WILL FOCUS ON
COMPLICATED CASES THAT SPAN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS. BUT
DELETE A DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL THEN REFER
RETAIL CRIME INVESTIGATIONS TO
THE DOJ'S CRIMINAL LAW DIVISION
FOR PROSECUTION. COULD YOU CHECK
THAT IN THE PROPOSAL WILL
SPECIFICALLY SUPPORT FIFTEEN
ENFORCEMENT POSITIONS IN THE
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. A
TOTALING THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION AND THIRTEEN LEGAL
POSITIONS IN OUR CRIMINAL LAW
DIVISION TOTALING TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION. ADULT THE DIVISION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATORS
WILL IMPLEMENT TO INVESTIGATIVE
TEAMS ARE IN THE NORTH AND IN
THE SOUTH REGION. AND WILL LIVE
WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CHP LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. OTHER
STATE AGENCIES AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT I'M JOINED TODAY BY
STEPHEN WOOLERY OUR CHIEF OF THE
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION AND WERE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON DOJ'S
PORTION OF THIS PROPOSAL- ON
THIS. THERE TO APPROVAL THE FEAR
OF THE FIRST WILL TAKE BE
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM. AGAIN
COMMENTS BY MY COLLEAGUE APPLY
SO WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON ON
BASICALLY A POTENTIAL OPTION FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION HERE-
SO AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA BEFORE
YOU ON THE TABLE THERE'S
ACTUALLY ANOTHER PROPOSAL THAT'S
GOING TO BE HEARD IN ANOTHER
SUBCOMMITTEE. THAT WOULD EXPAND
THE CHP ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME
TASK FORCES MADE MAKING THE
THREE EXISTING ONES PERMANENT
AND THEN ADDING TWO ADDITIONAL
ONES. AND SO IN THINKING OF THAT
TO THE EXTENT THE STATE IS
INTERESTED IN TARGETING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY COORDINATED BY
CRIMINAL GANGS AND NETWORKS. DOJ
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE A BETTER AND
TO T. TWO EVENTS EACH P. TO
ADMINISTER THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS. GIVEN THAT THEY HAVE
SIGNIFICANT EXPERTISE IN
MANAGING DEDICATED TASK FORCES
AS WELL AS MANAGING THOSE THAT
CONSIST OF FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL PARTNERS. DOJ ALSO EMPLOYS
BOTH- INVESTIGATOR PERSONAL AS
WELL AS ATTORNEYS WHICH COULD
HELP WITH THE INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION OF THOSE CASES
SUCCESSFULLY- WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT ON THE CHP FRONTS- THERE
COULD BE SOME STAFFING ISSUES
THAT COULD IMPACT. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TWO NEW
ONES BECAUSE OF THE HIGH VACANCY
RATE AND SO IN THE SHORT RUN OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS. THAT WOULD BE
GOING TO OVERTIME. RATHER THAN
DEDICATED OFFICERS WHICH COULD
IMPACT THE OUTCOMES. THE
TURNING- ARE. TO THE DOJ TASK
FORCE PROGRAM. THAT IS ONE WHERE
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER APPROVING
THE PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT WOULD
MAINTAIN DOJ'S PARTICIPATION IN
EIGHT EXISTING TASK FORCES. AND
THESE TYPES OF TASK FORCES CAN
BE A REALLY COST EFFECTIVE WAY.
OF ADDRESSING COMPLEX OR MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL CRIMES THAT HAVE
BOTH STATE AND REGIONAL IMPACT.
AND SO- A BIG PART OF THIS IS-
YOU KNOW EACH OF THE
PARTICIPATING AGENCIES FEDERAL
STATE OR LOCAL GENERALLY COVER
THEIR OWN COSTS- WHICH THEN
PROVIDES INCENTIVE THAT THE
CRIMES THAT ARE SELECTED WITHIN
EACH REGION. ARE THOSE THAT ARE
PRIORITIZED BY EACH OF THE
PARTICIPATING MEMBERS GENERALLY
THE MOST PRESSING THE MOST
COMPLEX FEDERA. SO MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER O'NEILL MENTIONED THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN CRIMES THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS. SO ONE OF
THE OPTIONS FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION IF ADDRESSING THIS
AND THAT COULD BE AS A PRIORITY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE IS TO
CONSIDER EXPANDING. THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT OPERATES REGIONALLY.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD HAVE
INCENTIVE TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE
THE COSTS WOULD BE SHARED. BUT
THE CASES THAT ARE BEING
ADDRESSED ARE- YOU KNOW WATER
IMPACTING THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
AND THE STATE WOULD ALSO BENEFIT
BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T BE PAYING
FOR THE FULL COST OF
INVESTIGATING THESE TYPES OF
CASES AND SO THAT'S JUST ANOTHER
OPTION FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON THISIS KEVIN CLARK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OVER MORE THAN HAPPY
TO. ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
EITHER THE BULLS. SO THE. THE
SHARES BACK. THEN AND THEN I'LL
START WITH. NOT REALLY A GOOD
QUESTION BT WHAT A COMMENT- IT
MIGHT EVEN BE A QUESTION OF.
WHEN I HAD MY HEARING AND IT
WOULD INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO-
MAKE SOME CHANGES TO ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT- THERE WAS A
COMMENT MADE IN A PRESS. WERE WE
WAITING FOR BATMAN WELL DOJ'S MY
BATMAN. BATMAN IS HERE IN THIS
IN IN PALATABLE FOR DOJ
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT CRIME
ENTERPRISES THAT'S THE PERSON I
WILL LOOK AT EVERYTHING ACROSS
JURISDICTION AND IN FACT- IF WE
COULD PUT A ZERO BEHIND THE SIX
IN A ZERO BEHIND A FIVE GOING TO
SCARE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
GUY. BUT THAT'S HOW MUCH FAITH I
HAVEN'T- THAT WE GO ALL OUT- TO
PROVIDE NADIA JURISDICTIONAL-
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO BUT
AGAIN- WORKING WITH CHP- TO
EXPAND THIS ACROSS THE STATE ON
TO MAKE IT EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE.
AND YOU DECIDE WHO'S BATMAN
WHO'S RODMOND. C. H. OR OR
BUDGET OR RETURN THE GENERAL BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY NOW YOU
HAVE. A STATE WIDE ENTITY.
THAT'S HANDLING THIS FOR MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AND YOU PUT PEOPLE
IN CHARGE OF THIS THAT'S BEEN
PART OF THE PROBLEM AND THEN YOU
DO A COMPREHENSIVE. PROGRAM THAT
STATEWIDE THAT EVERYBODY WILL
COME COMPORTMENT CONFORM TO. AND
SO- THAT. WHILE THE- THE NOTES I
HAD SAID THAT THE CHAIR HAD NO
COMMENT I JUST ONCE I AM A- ALSO
IN FULL AGREEMENT WITH IT
PROBABLY MORE SO. THEN WHAT L.
A- WANTED TO DO OR YOUR PARTNER
FINANCE WANTED TO DO THAT'S HOW
MUCH FAITH I HAVEN'T. THE WILL
GIVE IT BACK TO CHAIRS NOW BACK
. BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
LEADING THE CHARGE FOR US IN THE
QUESTIONS- I DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
QUESTIONS- I JUST LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ENSURE WE
GET MORE DETAILS. FOR THESE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS ALONG THE WAY
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE'RE GONNA START
WITH- ANYONE IN THE ROOM
PRESIDENT THAT WANTS TO DO
PUBLIC COMMENT. SCENE NINE I
WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP TO
THE PHONES. EACH PERSON WILL
HAVE A TWO ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT THIS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT SHOULD ALSO BE
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
STREAMING THIS HEARING. THE TOLL
FREE PHONE NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN- MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. YES IF
YOU IT IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT OVER
THE PHONE TODAY YOU CAN DO SO BY
PRESSING ONE BUTTON ZERO NET
COMMAND AGAIN IS ONE. ZERO AT
FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JENNIFER TO
I'M RESIDENTS OF OAKLAND WHAT
THE AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE I'M SPEAKING TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE. THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING LMAO HAS SAID THAT
PRISON POPULATION TRAPPING THAT
FIVE PRISON COULD BE CLOSED THE
NEXT YEAR. IT MAKES NO SENSE
PLEASE INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR PRESENT THAT AND SHOULD BE.
AND I OPPOSE ANY INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING TO CDCR. EARLIER WE ALSO
HEARD THAT MOST OF THE ITEMS
SEVEN PROJECTS ARE INCLUDED
BECAUSE THEIR CONTINUATION
PLANNING FROM PREVIOUS YEARS
THIS MAKES ME WONDER I
REQUESTING FUNDING FOR THESE
PROJECTS IS BASED ON SOME CALL
ALLSTATE REGARDLESS OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN REALITY SUCH AS
DROPPING PRISON POPULATIONS A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC FOR UPCOMING
PRECURSORS. IT SOUNDS LIKE CDCR
HAS HAD TROUBLE UNDERSTANDING
THE COMMITTEE'S REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION. AND IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMIT TO CLOSE
IN A SPECIFIC NUMBER PRESENTD.
THE TYPICALLY 8% BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. I FIND THAT NUMBER
WILL PROBABLY REMOVE THE
NECESSITY FOR AT LEAST HALF OF
ASSEMBLY NUMBER IN QUESTION.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
ISABELLA GORDON AND I WORK WITH
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AS WELL AS CRITICAL OVER
THE FENCE I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TEN YEAR
AFTER YEAR AT THE HOUSE WE ARE
REDUCE THE LONG TERM PLAN FOR
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CONSOLIDATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THINK POINT GUARD FAILURE REDUCE
THE PLANT HAS ALREADY RESULTED
IN OUR STATE WE IN BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON UNNECESSARY REPAIRS
AT PRESENT. WE NEED FOR CULTURE
TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THING
ACTIVITY ARE. STRUCTURE FUNDING
SPENT ON PRESENT THAT WE THEN
CLOSE WE WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
THAT ANSWER THANK BBC ARE COULD
NOT LAST FEBRUARY CHECK BACK
BEGIN NOTED THAT WE HAD ONLY HAD
THAT WE HAD ABOUT THE COST OF
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR RECENTLY
FOR D. B. I. PRISON BEFORE
LOOKING FOR CLOSURE BY SEPTEMBER
TO GET THEM. THIS INCLUDES
TWENTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HEALTH FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR ACTION
MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ELEVEN POINT SIX SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A SOLID DOOR FELT
SOLID YOUR FRIENDS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWO POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR NEW BORDER BOILER
FACILITY. AND CHECK THE GROWTH
IN THE FLAGRANT ASSUMPTION THAT
ALL OF THEIR FACILITIES
OPERATING TODAY WILL CONTINUE TO
OPERATE TEN YEARS FROM NOW IT'S
NOT ONLY FISCALLY IRRESPONSIBLE
BUT COMPLETELY OUT OF STEP WITH
THE WILL OF THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS IT IS CLEAR
FROM THE COMMENTS THAT THEY
THAT. NOTHING WRONG WITH THE S.
R. L. THEY SUBMITTED I ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE TO DENY ALL
PROPOSED SPENDING INCREASES THE
DVR FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS MORE
FUNDING FOR CDC ARE FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS WILL NOT MAKE A
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON MARQUEE
NAMESNOR OUR COMMUNITY SAFER WE
NEED TO PRIORITIZE PUBLIC SAFETY
BY MAKING THE COMMENT THANKS THE
STATE BANK THE COLD MORE
PRESENT. GIVEN THE REALITY OF
RECORD LOCAL PRISON POPULATION
NUMBERS ACROSS. THE STATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IN AT NINE. HELLO
MY NAME IS CHRISTY I AM FROM
GRANTS I'M A MEMBER CURB
REGARDING ISSUE NOT ONE I KNOW
MANDATE OF THE COMMITTEE IS TO
THE FISCAL CALL TO COME STATE
PRISON. BUT WE MUST NOT BE SIGHT
OF MORE COST OPERATING THE
PRISONS WITH YOU THINK. ALL
PRISON THE AND TRAUMA CENTER
RACISM AND LAND AIR AND NO
AMOUNT OF CAN THESE UNDENIABLE
ABOUT PRISON WHAT THE BEST
SOLUTION TO THE AND FISCAL CAR
OF THE HUMAN BEING IT'S CLOSE
PRISON INSTEAD OF PROPPING UP
FROM PRISON THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
BE ON SEVEN THEM DOWN FOR GOOD
NOT A WARM DOWN SHE IT DOWN I
ASKED THE COMMITTEE TO THE NIGHT
ALL INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING FOR.
THE ARTS AND COMMIT TO
ADDITIONAL PRISON CLOSURE THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE. THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE. LINE TWENTY
THIRD. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH FRASER AND I'M A
MEMBER OF SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE SEARCH BAY AREA- I TRULY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MADE
TODAY BY MANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
EXPRESSING YOUR STRONG
DISSATISFACTION WITH CDCR AND
ITS FAILURE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE INFORMATION YOU NEED TO MAKE
THAT THE RESPONSIBLE DECISION.
AS A TXPAYER I TOO AM EXTREMELY
DISSATISFIED AND FRUSTRATED BY
TCR'S LACK OF A RESPONSE FROM
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FIRST ANNOUNCED
HIS PLAN TO CLOSE TO PRISON OUR
PRISON POPULATION HAS DECREASED
BY MORE THAN TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND EVEN AFTER A MOTHER
FUTURE INCREASES IN OUR PRISON
POPULATION BUT STILL SUGGEST WE
CAN EASILY AND SAFELY BECAUSE
NUMEROUS ADDITIONAL PRINCETON
I'M TIRED OF BEING WASTEFUL
INFLATED SPENDING BY CDC ARE
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR THAT
IN NO. WAY CONTRIBUTE TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. HE SAID I HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR THAT CAN. AND IT WILL NOW
PROVIDE A LONG TERM PLAN
CRITICAL. AND SO I URGE THIS
GROUP FIFTY. TO TAKE THAT. AND
MAKE A PLAN CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET IS HERE
TO WORK WITH YOU ON CREATING A
SAFE AND ROBUST PLANNED FOR
PRISON CLOSURE. PLEASE DO NOT
WASTE ANOTHER YEAR ON CDC ARE IN
ACTION AND GET OUR BUDGET BACK
ON TRACK. THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY LINE THIRTY YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN I'M- CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK. I'M
CALLING TODAY FOR ITEM ONE ON
THE AGENDA MY NAME IS MEGAN
SHORT AND I'M A MEMBER OF CHURCH-BAY AREA AND ALSO OCCURRED- I
WAS I WAS COMPLETELY SHOCKED TO
LEARN- FROM TODAY'S AGENDA THAT
THE AVERAGE COST OF
INCARCERATION IN OUR STATE IS A
HUNDRED. FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PERSON PER YEAR. BUT
THAT FOUR TIMES THE COST OF AN
AVERAGE CALIFORNIA STATE COLLEGE
TUITION. I THINK OUR MONEY COULD
BE BETTER SPENT AND YOU WOULD
THINK THAT FOR THOSE DOLLARS
THAT PEOPLE NCARCERATED IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE RECEIVING
THE ROYAL TREATMENT. HOWEVER
THIS IS NOT EVEN CLOSE TO THE
TRUTH. THOSE INCARCERATED IN OUR
PRISONS OUR TEAM REGION COVERED
OUTBREAKS- AND DRINKING
POISONOUS WATER- BURGEONING
BUDGET IS TO KIND OF A PHRASE TO
DESCRIBE FEET YARDS OUTRAGEOUS
WASTEFUL AND IRRESPONSIBLE
SPENDING. THAT'S GOING ON YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR. IT'S TIME
TO DENY ALL INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING TO CDC ARE AND- TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
WASTEFUL SPENDING. WHAT CLOTHING
THAT'S COMMITTEE BACK FROM
DENYING ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING TO CDC
ARE AND GETTING OUR BUDGET BACK
ON TRACK WE SUPPORT YOU WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS DOING AND WE
ASK THAT YOU DENY ALL OF THE CDC
ARE INFRASTRUCTURE. FUNDING
THANK YOU. ALAINA TWENTY NINE. I
MY NAME BRIAN THE EIGHTY MEMBER
CRITICAL PRESIDENTE BOX AND
CLICK ON IT ABOUT ONE OF THE
FAMILY MEMBERS JONES SAWYER CAN
GARCIA REMINDED JUST LAST YEAR
FIVE OF FIVE HEARING BODY
CLEARLY GOT THE PR FOR FORT SO
THAT WHEN THE LONG TERM I'M A
DIFFICULT CONSOLIDATE. DAY
WITHOUT THAT PLAN AS WE ARE
PROVIDED BY THE SEA CARE ON MANY
THE ISSUES OUTLINED BY THE
LEGISLATURE OF THIS IMPACTS
TAKES ME AS WELL PEARL WILL PULL
I'M COOPERATIVE. REALLY AND- I
WANNA URGE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT TAKES CALL PATCH
REGARDING BUDGET NOW TO NOT ALL
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND UNDERGONE
CDC ARE SHOULD INSTEAD GO TO BE
INVESTED IN CAMINO THAT ARE BY
THE LAW STAND CRISIS BECAUSE I
YOU LIKE SOME OF THE- TO CLOSE
EIGHT ADDITIONAL PRISON ON IT.
FIVE I HAVE EITHER THE TO PRINT
OUT CURRENT- ARE EX BE CURSOR
BASED. CAN HELP IN THE FORWARD
WITH THE- THANK YOU. FIND
THIRTY. HELLO MY NAME ANGELA BE
ON AND I WITH THIRDS CRUZ- I IT
IS THE CLEAR THAT WE ARE BOOKED
REFUSING TO PROVIDE A LONG TERM
PLAN INCLUDE. AND I AM AS
FRUSTRATED AS NUMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THEIR LACK OF
RESPONSIVENESS- AND AS SUCH I
REALLY URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
RECOMMEND FREEZING THEIR BUDGET
OR EVEN TO DECREASING IT. UNTIL
THEY CAN PROVIDE A CONCRETE AND
REASONABLE PLAN FOR PRISON
CULTURE- AND THAT- I WOULD NOT
BE THE LEGISLATURE NAKED SOME
PLAN IF YOU GONNA DO IT THERE
ARE CERTAINLY OTHER PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT. SO
AGAIN I. SUPPORT YOU. FOR ALL
YOUR WORK AND PAINT YOU AND I AM
YOU TO EXPAND. FIND A. THIRTY
THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS VICTOR
AND THE OTHER THAN THE
TRANSISTOR BAY AREA AND A MEMBER
OF TRIPLE EXISTENCE OAKLAND
CHAPTER I'M ALSO CALLING TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
THAT'S ONLY AGREE WITH THE
SOMEBODY IN THE OFFICE THAT
FIFTIES ERA CAN INDUSTRY
BURGEONING BUDGET. MEDIAMATEC
ARE TO STOP. FROM CONTINUING TO
TALKED MONEY ON INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS AFTER BACK. OR MUSK
. START MONEY ON INFRASTRUCTURE
ON COMMUNITIES BERNIE OF RESTORE
THAT ARE BASED THE KING. OF
MONEY ON WHEN WE NEED TO THAT
YOU. HOUSING HEALTH CARE. THE
STATION I ALL FUNDING THAT YOU
SEE ARE. AND HOLD IT AND ALSO
LIKE YOU KNOW A FLOATING BETWEEN
THE BACK INTO NINE ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING THE GDPR
. AND TAKING THE MORE PRESENT
CLOSE. BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE
SHOULD BE CLOSING EIGHT
PRESIDENT AND DIVERTING ALL
THOSE TO. THAT HAVE BEEN FOR
DECADES NEGLECTED FONG PURPOSE
YOU MIGHT SACRAMENTO AND
BUILDING UP. YOU KNOW OUR PEOPLE
THANK YOU. BLIND. FOUR HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. HI MY NAME IS
SARAH ROBINSON AND ARE THEY
CALLING FROM FOR THE CALIFORNIA
AND TODAY I WAS AND I'M CALLING
REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER ONE AND-
THERE WAS STRUCK BY THE SEVERE
LACK OF CLARITY ON JUDICIARY'S
RESPONSIVENESS AND HOW THEY
PRIORITIZE THE MISSION THEY'RE
PUTTING MONEY INTO ON WHY THIS
WAS DEMONSTRATED BY THEIR LACK
OF ABILITY TO SPEAK TO THE
PROJECTED DATA AND TO TRACK THE
DATA OF SHRINKING PRISON
POPULATION. IF I COULD VISION
AND CLARITY TRANSLATE INTO
CALIFORNIA GIVING CPR. FREE REIN
ON SPENDING. IT IS UNHEARD OF TO
INVEST IN INITIATIVE THAT HAVE A
BIG PUSH. FOR DECISION MAKING
AND WALL TERM. I AT THIS POINT.
ADDING SOMETHING MONEY AT THE
BASED ON MY- AND IT'S NOT MINE
WITH DATA THE NEW AND THAT IS.
VETERANS WITH THE BUDGET AND FOR
CALIFORNIANS LIVE OUTRAGEOUS
INCOMPETENT AND WASTEFUL THE
TIME IS NOW TO DENY ALL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING TO CDCR
AND IT'S HONESTLY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE A MINIMAL RESPONSE
TO THE LACK OF PROFESSIONALISM
TRAINING AND COMPETENCE OF THE
SHERIFF'S BUDGET. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF COMMITTEES FOR YOUR
CLEAR QUESTIONING AND COMMITMENT
TO RESPONSIBLE SPENDING AND
ADDITIONAL PRISON CLOSURE WHICH
IS REALLY CONSISTENT WITH OUR
RESIDENTS VALUES SUCH AS MYSELF.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. A LINE OF.
THIRTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIGN AND WANT TO
CHECK THEM POLITICAL DIRECTOR
CRITICAL RESISTANCE ALSO A
MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA HAS SOME
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET IN SAN JOSE I
DON'T THINK THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION TO SEE SHOWERS
WASTEFUL SPENDING PARTICULARLY
FOR THE COMMENTS RICHARD GARCIA
NUMBERS TENGAN JONES SAWYER
STATING OBVIOUS IT'S A CRUCIAL.
CRUCIATUS CAREER ON THE NUMBERS
AND LACKLUSTER RESPONSES FROM
CVC ARE IS THAT IT IS INCUMBENT
ON THE COMMITTEE TO
CATEGORICALLY REJECT GDPR'S
REQUEST FOR MORE FUNDING INTO
TRAFFIC HE ARTICLES MORE PRISONS
YEAR AFTER YEAR CDCR SHIRK
RESPONSIBILITY THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THIS UNLESS THIS
COMMITTEE TAKES ACTION TO BRING
THEM IN. WE HAVE SEEN THEM
PRISON POPULATION STEADILY
DECLINED IT'S YOU SEE OUR BUDGET
EVELYN BALLOON OVER THE YEARS
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OVERALL
BUDGET A WHOLE CHUNK OF HI FROM
TAXPAYERS AND NOT JUST A
PARTICULAR LINE ITEMS THAT IT
HAS SCOTT HAS. DEPARTMENT
FINANCING TO REFER TO. JUST TO
MAKE AN ON POPULOUS. IN LOOKING
UP A LOT TEN YEAR OF CITIES OWN
. AGAINST POPULATION NUMBERS AND
THE CITY HAS. LOADED PROJECTIONS
. AND IN DOING SO IT HAS JUST A
BALLOONING BY. MY COLLEAGUES
TALKED ABOUT THE FIFTY MILLION
AT D. V. I. WERE SCHOOL AS IT
WAS. I THINK TWENTY ONE APPROVED
SCORE COMPLETED PROJECTS FOR
CONSTRUCTION AT CCC AND
SUSANVILLE WAS APPROVED AT SIXTY
FOUR MILLION THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
BETWEEN TWO PRESENTS HAVING
SLATED FOR CLOSURE GDPR HAS
SPENT OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS MONEY HAS BEEN
SQUANDERED AN THAT IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE. I CAN'T THINK OF
ANOTHER STATE AGENCY THAT WOULD
BE GRANTED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OFFICIALS EVEN A FRACTION OF
INCOMPETENCE INABILITY TO
PROVIDE SIMPLE ANSWERS TO
QUESTIONS THREE WEEKS YOU ARE
SHOWING YOUR YEAR. I ALSO CAN'T
THINK OF A SINGLE OTHER STATE
SYSTEM AGENCY THAT HAS AS MUCH
FUN USED OPERATING CAPACITY SCDC
ART IS ASKING TO BINGE FOUR
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS OF
CONSTRUCTION. THIS IS ABSURD. IT
ON THE COMMITTEE YOU HAVE
BACKING OF CALIFORNIA BOTH.
TAXPAYERS AND RESIDENTS. TO CD'S
ARE IN AND TO PUT THAT. BACK IN
CAN BE WHERE IT HAS AS- THANK
YOU. BLINDED TWENTY. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- MEMBERS- MANY JOBS
JELA ON BEHALF A FIFTEEN ANTI
TRAFFICKING ESTABLISH THAT THEY
LOOK AT A LOCAL I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE IF HE
CLEAN NUMBER ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
POINT IN THAT ITEM IT'S A POOR
OKAY ABOLITION AND PROVIDING
THAT- TO MAKE SURE THAT AB TWO
SIX TWO WHICH PROVIDE PUT
CONVICTION THE VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED AND. WITH THAT I
THINK IF I CAN'T. BLYDE. THIRTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS I'M
ONLY HERE I AM THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ON ISSUE ONE AND
TWO AND I HAD MANY OF THE
CALLERS SHARE THE COMMITTEE
FRUSTRATION- AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND ASKING HER
QUESTIONS TO THE DEPARTMENT.
LET'S ASSUME THAT THE BBC ARE
WILL NOT PROVIDE A PLAN THIS
YEAR NEXT YEAR WHATEVER AND TKR
IS SUPPOSED TO BE A SYSTEM ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CONSEQUENCES
WHAT MESSAGE DO WE SEND IF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
DON'T HOLD BACK THING PRISON
SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GUNFIRE POINTED OUT QUOTE
CRIMINALS ARE REALLY SMART AND
KNOW HOW TO GET TO GET AROUND
PAYING. THIS LOGIC EASILY BE
APPLIED TO THE BEHAVIOR WE'VE
SEEN YEAR AFTER YEAR AND THIS
COMMITTEE. FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS. AND THIS IS WHY
ARE SAFETY BUDGET IS OUT OF
CONTROL. LOOK THE NUMBERS AS OF
LAST WEEK OUR PRESENT. WAS A BIT
OVER NINETY TWO THOUSAND LEVELS
THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE. WHEN OUR
STATE OPERATED TWELVE FEWER
PRISONS AND SPENT TWELVE BILLION
LEFT ANNUALLY ON CORRECTIONS
THAT WE ARE TODAY. SO LET'S BE
CLEAR NO ADDITIONAL MONEY OR
RESOURCES WILL HELP CDCR MAKE
THESE DECISIONS FOR YOU. WHAT WE
NEED IS TO LOOK AT OTHER WAYS
THAT E'VE HELD AND- BODIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR MAKING THESE
TYPES OF BUDGET DECISIONS SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T PASS THE STATE BUDGET BY
JUNE FIFTEENTH. BY LAW
LEGISLATORS DON'T GET PAID WHAT
IF INNOCENT INSTANCE THE DVR
DOESN'T GET PAID NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF SALARY BUT IN TERMS OF
ALLOCATION AFTER ALLOCATION
AFTER APPLICATION WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS COMMITTEE AND
MAKING BOLD MOVES AND HAVING
STRONG CONSEQUENCES HERE. THAT
THAT MAKES US A CONTINUE TO HOLD
THE SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE HAVING A
REDUCED PRISON POPULATION IS A
CHOICE. IT IS NOT THAT THE SHIFT
AND THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN OUR PEOPLE HAVE
CHOSEN TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION AND LET'S TO DO THAT
NOW AND FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
AND YOU CAN DO THAT BY DENYING
ALL INFRASTRUCTURE. THERE ARE
IMMINENT AND COMMITTING TO IT.
YEAH AND TO IT TOO ADDITIONAL
PERMANENT CLOSURES NOW. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. A LINE OF. FORTY
KEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
HOME DEPOT IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S. ALL THANK YOU. BLIND. FORTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS
RYAN ELAINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AND I'LL
BE SPEAKING ISSUED THREE TODAY
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
ENHANCE ENFORCEMENT OF ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME MITIGATING
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME IN RESULT
THAT'S REQUIRES A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY THAT ATTACKS A PROBLEM
EVERY LEVEL IN THIS BUDGET
PACKAGE IS VITAL TO THE START
DISRUPTING OR ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME OUR STATE. COMPETITIVE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT GRANT AND
COMPETITIVE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY GRANTS WILL PROVIDE
LOCAL AGENCIES WITH THE
RESOURCES TO SUSTAIN RESULT THAT
INVESTIGATIONS THROUGH WEEKS AND
MONTHS- THAT OFTEN REQUIRED
INDICATED PROSECUTORS DOUBLE THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS ARE ALSO
NEEDED AS MANY ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT CASES HAVE LANGUISHED FOR
YEARS RESULTING FROM LOCAL
AGENCY RESOURCE LIMITATIONS WE
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THE
SUPPORT PROPOSAL. AND ORDER
SUPPORT AGREEMENT. I AM A. FORTY
THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS JOE ONE
THE NUMBER AGAIN I'M A MEMBER
CURRENT SYSTEM CONNECTING TO
COMMITTEE CLINIC HERE TO- BUT I
MUST SAY THIS COMMITTEE
MCLAUGHLIN A BILLING OR EVEN BY. WHAT IS PVC ARE INCOMPETENT.
LAST YEAR THE BUT- BY HEARING
FIFTY CLEARLY- ACTIVITIES RECORD
REPORT BUT OUT BELOW TERM PLANS.
FOR CLOSING CLOSE AND
CONSOLIDATION. AND HERE WE ARE
TODAY WITH NO SUCH THING. GEN
DONALD. THAT THE S. R. L.
PROVIDED BY CDCR WAS ON THE
PHONE TOO MANY OF THE ISSUES
OUTLINED BY THE LEGISLATORS TO
ME THIS IS MORE THAN JUST ON
WITH NO MORE THAN JUST BEING
UNRESPONSIVE THIS IS SUPPORT THE
NATION EVERYTHING. AND I URGE
YOU TO TAKE CONCRETE BOLD ACTION
REGARDING FEEDING. BUDGET NOW
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. LINE.
TWENTY FIVE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD OF. BOB THIS IS JANE THE
KORAN I AM A MEMBER OF STANDING
UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE AS WELL
AS- A FORMER VOLUNTEER AND- BILL
OF OUR STATE PRISONS- I JUST
WANT THIS COMMITTEE TO KNOW HOW
MUCH WE DO APPRECIATE YOU AND
HOW- YOU'RE QUESTIONING TODAY. I
HAS REALLY REVEALED US THE
INCOMPETENCY IN THE IN TRANSIT.
TRANSACTION OF CDC ARE I THINK
THAT YOUR DELIBERATIONS HERE
GIVE YOU HE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY- CUT THROUGH THE CRAP I'M
SORRY TO USE THIS LANGUAGE BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GETTING TODAY
FROM C. OUR INCARCERATION IS AN
ONGOING HUMANITARIAN CRISIS. IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS BLACK
BROWN INDIGENOUS AND POOR
COMMUNITY AND ALL WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT TODAY OUR PUNITIVE
MEASURES- I'M GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING- YOUR BUDGET NUMBER
THREE- YOUR EXCUSE ME YOUR
AGENDA NUMBER THREE AS WELL AS
YOU WANT AND I WANT TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION. TO A VERY CREATIVE
SOLUTION ON THE PART OF SENATOR
NANCY SKINNER WHO SUBMITTED SB
THREE OH ONE THIS YEAR A BILL
THAT WOULD CRACK DOWN ON RETAIL
CANNELLA MORNING BY NOT ALLOWING
THEM TO STEP UP TO RETAIL. GOODS
ONLINE- LINE OF THIS. FOR ONE
ONE. HI MY NAME IS THAT WOULD BE
A GOOD FOR MORE THAN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA NUMBER OF KIRBY
CALIFORNIA UNITED KERR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET ON BEHALF OF
KERR MEMBERSHIP IN OVER A
THOUSAND RIGHT WING COMMENTATORS
COMMITTEE IN RESPONSE TO ISSUE
ONE URGES COMMITTEE TO DENY ALL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING TO SEE IF
YOU ARE INTO COMBAT TO
ADDITIONAL PERSONAL CLOSURE. I
THINK IT'S COMMITTEES COMMENT ON
THIRTY THREE AREN'T OUTRAGEOUS
RACIST AND UNCHECKED COULDN'T
SPENDING COMPARED INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING COMBINED WITH THE BLACK
OF PLANT APPROVAL CLOSURE AND
CONSOLIDATION DANGER TO HUMAN
LIFE EXTREMELY WASTEFUL.
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN IS THE PRINT
COULDN'T SPENDING SPREE IT'S NOT
ABOUT CONTINUITY OF SERVICE
PEOPLE CARE ARE THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION TRUTHFULLY THIS IS
NEVER BEEN A PRIORITY FOR CPR
UNTIL THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THREATENED IT IS IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT CHIU INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC SAFETY AND HEALTH ARCHIE
TO PRISON CLOSURE AND
REDIRECTING FUNDS TO OUR
COMMUNITY NOT MORE PRUDENT
SPENDING. IF YOU'RE REVISED
BUDGET WILL DETERMINE IF YOU ARE
THE ROUND FOR ANOTHER FIFTY
YEARS- WE IMPLEMENT POINTS
AFFECTING CLOSURE THAT IS BOTH
THE L. A. L. KIRKPATRICK
BLIGHTED APPEARANCE HE WAIT A
THIS IS A GUARANTEED WAY TO
PROVIDE TRUE PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS I URGE YOUR
LEADERSHIP TO HOLD YOU
ACCOUNTABLE AND CREATE A
DIFFERENT PASSWORD BY CLICKING
CLICKING AND GOING WILL HELP
YOUR INPUT. AB THANK YOU SO MUCH
. AND WE HAVE NO FOR COMMENT AT
THE TIME. THANK YOU L. A. TO
THANK THE MODERATOR- THE
PANELISTS THE PEOPLE THAT
TESTIFIED. PUBLIC COMMENTS AS-
THE MEMBER ALLEGING.
HI MY FROM. REPORTER. YOU
ADDRESS. MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PAULINE. ASSEMBLY BROKE AND YOU
LIVE. OKAY. PEOPLE WATCHING
REALLY HAPPY ABOUT IT THEY'RE
LIKE IN THE ROOM WHEN I WAS
TRYING TO MAKE SURE YOUR- I KNOW
. THINK A LOT OF HEADWATERS.
WHAT KIND OF YEAH. I THINK CLARK
OR SOMETHING I DON'T KNOW WHY WE
DON'T. THEY MAKE ME WANT TIMELY
AND. AND THEY DON'T FALL OFF.
I'LL TEXT YOU WHEN I. YEAH THANK
YOU YEAH GOT TO BE THE SHOOT
MYSELF HE YEAH. I FEEL NINE
OTHER WAS ONLY CASE NOW.